de la défense et des forces armées chère
Catherine
Dumar mes chers
collègues permettez-moi de saluer ceux
qui vont être cœur de notre soirée
d'abord le directeur de la revue grand
continent Gill cressani et Matthéo malic
le rédacteur en chef et puis bien sûr
ceux qui vont être au cœur de nos débats
Jérôme Fourquet que je ne présente pas
Giovanni Orsina professeur d'histoire
contemporaine et directeur de la School
of governement à
l'universitéis GUID Carly à Rome et puis
Françoise fressos que je ne présente pas
non plus vous regardez ses éditoriaux je
m'adresse aux nombreux étudiant ici
présents je n'en doute pas avec
régularité et
donc vous
tous chers étudiants mesdames et
messieurs je suis heureux d'ouvrir cette
trème rencontre du grand continent ici
au Sénat après deux premiers rendez-vous
souv vous sur les rivalités
géopolitiques et le rôle des parlements
en Europe cette 3è séance clos un
premier cycle d'échange
oui merci à G crad mattho qui au nom de
la revue le grand continent ont rendu
possible ce partenariat et je souhaite
qu'il puisse aboutir à une publication
commune je me suis engagé pour ce
nouveau qui a commencé au début du mois
dernier a continué de cultiver les
synergies entre notre assemblée et le
monde de la recherche et plus
généralement renforcer notre ouverture
sur le monde extérieur et c'est ce que
nous partageons notamment avec les
président de
commission je crois sincèrement que ces
échanges nourrissent le travail
parlementaire et qui contribue à placer
le Sénat au cœur de l'actualité mais
aussi au cœur des préoccupations des C
cityen dans ces temps où la confiance
des Français à l'égard des élus se
heurte à des modes de gouvernance
verticaux nous nous devons de multiplier
ces ponts me semble-t-il entre les
institutions de la République
entre le monde universitaire et de la
recherche mais aussi nos concitoyens
mesdames et messieurs il nous revient
aujourd'hui d'essayer ensemble de
proposer des clés de réflexion pour
mieux comprendre cet embrasement
français dans un paysage au multiples
fractures dans cette France
archipélisé comme le décrit Jérôme
fourqu c'est le constat partagé que
chaque sénateur au fond pourrait vous
raconter peu de territoire sont épargnés
par ce syndrome que j'avais appelé la
france d' côté dans un rapport en 2015
rapport François Hollande après les
attentats que nous avions vécu
je l'ai dit et je l'ai rappelé au
président actuel de la République à
l'heure où notre pays sortait grogi de
la réforme des retraites et après avoir
éprouvé la crise des gilets jaunes puis
la crise sanitaire nous devons retrouver
de la proximité et du dialogue pour
recou de ce pays les maires sont en
première ligne à chaque fois que
l'autorité de l'État vacille et que la
République est attaquée souvenez-vous le
début de l'ét
516 communes touché par des émeutes et
près de 700 infraction commise
directement contre des élus est-ce que
ça n'est pas un témoignage éclairant
nous pouvons pas rester mu face à
l'enlisement de ces Frances face à face
que redoutait Gérard
Colomb la seule réponse au crime de CRP
et plus généralement à la violence ne
peut-être que l' de droit mais attention
aussi aux deux poids de
mesure la mort de Thomas n'est pas un
fait divers c'est aussi le témoignage du
déchirement de notre
société
l'école alors que l'école de la
République est au cœur des enjeux de
violence et de sécurité qui traversent
le pays elle n'est plus aujourd'hui
vraiment le lieu de transmission des
savoirs où le maître est respecté et
pourtant tout commence à
l'école ce que vous décrivez Jérôme
forquet dans la tribune paru lundi
dernier et coécrite avec Jean-Pierre
legof je vous cite la dstructuration du
tissu éducatif de la famille et de
l'école qui joue pourtant un rôle
décisif pour se sociabiliser et acquérir
une morale commune fin de
citation je voudrais évoquer avec vous
deux phénomène consubstantiel me
semble-t-il de l'embrasement français
qui me paraît comme tout
pouvoir consumer l'unité nationale et
désagréger le contrat
social tout d'abord l'explosion de la
violence à toutes les strades de notre
société et j'y reviens à l'encontre des
élus et au sein de l'école de la
République et la crise de l'autorité les
symboles républicains qui fond le
contrat social et doivent demeurer
l'indispensable Lian qui nous permet de
faire société dans un monde au multiples
bouleversement
ce double phénomène ébranle plus
particulièrement deux piliers essentiels
de notre démocratie la commune les
enseignants au cœur de l'école de la
République la semaine dernière plus de
6000 élus locaux ont été accueillis au
Sénat à l'occasion du congrès des maires
de France sur un thème je le cite
commune attaqué République menacée à
terme certes un peu
anxiogène mais qui me paraît révélateur
du ressenti des élus car la commune
cette petite république dans la grande
au fond révèle beaucoup des
violences l'an dernier vous l'avez tous
en tête ça a été répété mais quand même
les agressions contre les élus ont
augmenté de 32 % et dans l'enquête du
svov de la semaine dernière de Martial
fou
69% des Mair % des Mair déclar avoir été
victime
d'incivilité
l'école qui est aussi le lieu cardinal
de l'intégration républicaine
indispensable corollaire à une
immigration maîtrisée et traversé par
une crise multiple c'est d'abord une
crise de l'autorité quand 52 % des
enseignants
s'autocensure et que parents et élèves
contestent les enseignements et
l'autorité du
maître c'est
aussi l'explosion des atteintes à la
laïcité plus 120 % cette
année je crois que ce que nous avons
vécu dans mon département à Conflant
saint-honorine
ou dans le Pas de calé à haras appelle
une réponse forte de la République et le
refus sans délai du pas de vague qui a
isolé les enseignants et entretenu la
peur on peut pas accepter que l'école
soit le lieu de l'affrontement entre
défenseur de la laïcité et provocation
de l'islam politique c'est enfin la
prolifération du harcellement qui se
poursuit sur les réseaux sociaux bien
au-delà de l'école où la violence est
débridée et
banalisée alors faut-il et je reprends
des
mots constater l'ensuvagement de notre
société et s'en tenir
là là où saurons-nous où saons-nous
encore faire nation point
d'interrogation que sera la France
d'après si nous ne répondons pas à ces
questions attention à ceux qui tentent
de travestir la
réalité pour motiver leurs ambitions
politiques personnelles parce que la
réalité nos compatriotes la ressent
personnellement et directement attention
la peur de nommer les choses qui conduit
au mensonge par omission et dégrade le
vivre ensemble et éode la
confiance je reste un optimiste
souvenez-vous lors de notre dernière
rencontre j'avais cl mon propos en
citant Churchill évoquant la
souveraineté populaire je récidive ce
soir face au défis qui nous
attend je le cite un pessimiste voit la
difficulté dans chaque opportunité un
optimiste à l'opportunité dans chaque
difficulté nous vivons c'est vrai une
tentation à la fois individualiste et
communautaire mais je crois que nous ne
pouvons pas renoncer à l'universalisme
qui nous a construit la France d'après
ne peut pas être la France d'Orange
Mécanique de Stan les Cubric où la
violence est érigée en valeur je ne me
résoudrai pas à ce que dans notre pays
un maire ou un enseignant exerce ses
missions de la sécurité je ne me
résoudrai jamais à ce qu'un nos
compatriote ne puisse vivre en sécurité
dans son
quartier du
fait de sa religion de son origine ou de
son refus d'accepter la violence
li au
narcrafic nous avons donc besoin d'un
sursut alors je laisse sans plus tarder
la parole à Jérôme fourqu Giovan or et
Françoise press après les propos que
nous tiendrons l'équipe de grand
continent bienvenue au
Sénat monsieur le Président c'est
toujours très difficile d'intervenir
aprè après vous nous sommes vraiment
ravis de pouvoir le faire pour la
troisème fois avec ce partenariat qui
tient qui nous tient à cœur le grand
routinant a choisi le le Sénat pour
développer un parcours un cycle de
conférence et d'échange dont on voit
aujourd'hui l'aboutissement du ce
premier
cycle l'idée ça pouvait être un peu
étonnante parce que le grandtinette il n
aurit vu surtout en ligne même si
évidemment on a une édition papier et
Giovanni hsina qui qui vous parlera qui
nous parlera à contribué à la dernière
livraison c'est surtout une revue en
ligne elle est surtout gérée par une
équipe plutôt jeune l'âge moyen je crois
c'est plutôt 29 ans donc certaines
personnes des mauvaises langues ont pu
nous nous dire qu'est-ce que vous allez
faire au Sénat en réalité c'est vraiment
très évident ce qu'on va faire au Sénat
on fait ce qu'on fait dans le web mais
dans un cadre institutionnel qui qui est
particulièrement propice parce que si on
essaie de faire quelque chose d'un peu
différent par rapport à ce qu'on peut
retrouver dans le dans l'espace dans
l'espace du débat c'est précisément
parce qu'on essaie de prendre du recul
de réfléchir sur les instants les temps
longs les structures et c'est ici dans
cette maison que c'est c'est ici dans
cette maison qu'on peut particulièrement
bien réussir C exercices complexes qui
consistent à essayer de regarder de très
près des problèmes des sujets qui sont
incandescents vous avez parlé justement
d'unbrassement pour essayer de les
articuler et de comprendre avec les
instruments qui sont ceux de la
dialectique de la raison et donc c'est
vraiment pour cela que ce soir nous
sommes ravis de de de pouvoir vous
accueillir de pouvoir accueillir les
intervenants pour cette première cette
première premier tour de de table ronde
et on vous remercie encore une fois pour
votre
accueil merci beaucoup je réitère ses
remerciements monsieur le Président on
est est vraiment très très heureux de à
chaque fois pouvoir avoir ces occasions
d'échange et je ne répéterai pas sur sur
ceadigil à quel point c'est aussi
important pour nous et important de
toujours traiter des thèmes qui nous
assaill en quelque sorte qui sont des
thèmes d'actualité mais avec une
perspective un peu au long cours et avec
ce soir un panel je pense vraiment assez
exceptionnel euh Jérôme Fourquet
giovannie Orsina et Françoise fressos
donc merci aussi beaucoup à vous trois
d'avoir accepté d'avoir accepté de vous
prêter à cette à cet exercice et ce soir
aussi un format un peu un peu différent
des autres puisque euh nous intégrons
beaucoup plus aussi les interventions de
sénateurs et nous en sommes très honorés
avec l'intervention du président de la
commission des lois François Noël buffet
euh celle de Catherine Duma la
vice-présidente de la Commission des
Affaires étrangères du Sénat et enfin
celle de Laurent Laffond président de la
commission de la culture de l'éducation
et de la communication du Sénat on voit
à quel point au fond euh la thématique
les questions dont nous avons à à à
connaître et à parler ce soir touche des
sujets aussi aussi différents et
d'ailleurs je pense que le mot
embrasement pour cela mais je pense
qu'on on y reviendra dit déjà en quelque
sorte cette impossibilité à maîtriser le
feu en quelque sorte à maîtriser cette
cette cette cet aspect incandescent dont
on sait pas trop d'où partir comment le
comment le contenir et au fond euh je
pense que les questions que que nous
allons essayer de nous poser ce soir et
et auxquelles nos trois nos trois
intervenants vont essayer de de répondre
dans leurs interventions respectives
sont tout à fait en ligne avec ce qu'on
essaie de faire dans dans la revue
c'est-à-dire vraiment traiter de
problèmes qui a priori sont très
difficiles à percevoir qui nous étonnent
qui sur lesquels on narrive pas
forcément même à à mettre de mots
parfois vous avez évoqué président euh
les les les les voilà l'actualité
récente enfin il est il est très
difficile en fait même de décrire ce qui
ce qu'on ce qu'on est en train de vivre
donc je pense que c'est ces moments
d'échange comme comme celui de ce soir
j'espère en tout cas sont une occasion
assez parfaite et pour ça merci encore à
vous euh je je donne du coup voilà sans
plus attendre la parole à à Jérôme
Fourquet pour la première
intervention merci beaucoup euh bonsoir
à toutes et bonsoir à tous monsieur le
président euh merci pour votre pour
votre invitation
euh donc l'intervention va prendre euh
comme cadre le le le sujet de la
conférence l'embrasement de la France
donc on est sur des termes qui sont très
fort est-ce qu'on se paye de mots euh ou
non je pense que si on essaie de regard
de prendre un peu de recul et de
regarder la la réalité en face il y a
quand même effectivement euh des
éléments de d'inquiétude à avoir des
élément él de
préoccupation qui sont pas nouveaux ces
éléments dont on a déjà euh
parlé dans nombreuses tribunes
publications ouvrages donc je sais que
le président du du Sénat partage
aussi toute une série de de diagnostis
au regard de sa connaissance des
territoires français son contact
quotidien avec les les élus locaux et
donc la
question
que je vais essayer de traiter dans
lapse de temps assez court donc on va
prendre quelques raccourcis je m'en
excuse d'avance c'est un peu essayer de
remettre un cadre sur comment on est on
est-on arrivé là sachant que ce sera
ensuite et moi j'ai le rôle facile au
politique éventuellement d'essayer de
réfléchir à des des solutions à des
réponses à apporter
euh je je je j'aborderai deux deux deux
points euh en terme de
d'intensité des difficultés des des des
tensions que
ces points peuvent générer dans la
société tout d'abord je voudrais revenir
sur une notion qui a était assez
controversée que j'appelle la
décivilisation on va parler d'érosion du
processus de civilisation donc on va
revenir sur sur ces sur sur cette notion
et puis dans un deè temps je voudrais
évoquer un problème gigantesque qui est
à la source de bien des difficultés de
bien des quartiers en France et quand on
regarde encore une fois le drame de
crpole quand on gratte un peu on voit
les traces de de ce phénomène là c'est
l'emprise croissante du narcotrafic sur
toute une partie de notre territoire
national alors tout d'abord sur cette
question de la la décivilisation
euh j'essaie de réfléchir à un certain
nombre de phénomènes qu'on peut
constater que euh le président Larcher a
a énuméré et qui consiste
à une montée des
tensions de l'électricité de
l'agressivité dans les relations
interpersonnelles dans tous les
compartiments de la société et donc on
n'est pas là forcément sur le grand
banditisme sur le drame de de Crépol on
est sur les invectives vis-à-vis des
élus locaux sur euh l'attitude on va
dire ça comme ça très peu courtoise et
civilisée d'une partie du public
vis-à-vis du personnel de guichet dans
les administrations dans des banques
vis-à-vis des caissières dans les
supermarchés
euh sur des tensions qui existe aussi
dans les les transports en commun
rappelez-vous des dramatiques affaires
avec des des des chauffeurs de bus avec
demande d'exercice du droit de retrait
mais euh si on dézoome un petit peu on
constate la même chose sur les terrains
de foot amateur
où la Ligue Française de foot amateur a
mis en place un observatoire des
incivilités puisque les hommes en noir
alors ils ont pas toujours eu bonne
presse hein on le sait mais euh jusqu'à
il y a une vingtaine ou une trentaine
d'années c'était surtout des colibets
qu'il pouvaient recevoir aujourd'hui
c'est parfois autre chose et une partie
d'entre eux raccroche le sifflet face à
la montée de de ces tensions euh il a
été question aussi de l'école avec la la
la montée de cette ces incivilités euh
et le fait que on constate qu'il
s'agisse du professeur de l'élu
local du médecin le médecin de ville ou
le médecin de campagne du pharmacien du
pompier toute une série de figures
républicaines qui jusqu'à il y a une
trentaine d'années étaient encore
protégé par un statut et une une
légitimité et bien sont à leur tour
confronté à cette montée de la tension
de l'incivilité voire parfois euh de la
de la violence avec toutes ces
institutions qui
euh ont appris ou essaye de vivre avec
cela donc je vous ai parlé des de la
Ligue de football amateur mais euh vous
voyez que euh l'association des maire
de- France
euh le l'ordre des médecins l'Ordre des
pharmaciens tout le monde a mis en place
progressivement son observatoire des
violences et des incivilités alors ça
règle pas le problème on essaie de
diagnostiquer cela euh chez les pompiers
professionnels on fait remonter
systématiquement maintenant les
violences que les hommes du feu encaisse
au au quotidien et dans les services
d'urgence des hôpitaux nous avons
aujourd'hui des services de sécurité
hein et donc c'est plein de petits
signes comme ça qui nous font toucher du
doigt cette montée des
tensions autre petit signe on revient
sur le drame de crpole
euh la première personne qui était
blessée lors de ce drame était un vigile
qui était présent à l'entrée de la salle
des fêtes il y avait eu quatre vigiles
qui avaient été engagé parce que
aujourd'hui dans chaque fête de village
il faut désormais compte tenu du climat
ambiant qui règne que des vigiles soient
présents et donc l'idée de pas tout
repeindre en rose
et les sénateurs qui ont est connaissent
bien le le terrain savent que
historiquement on sait souvent castag
dans des balles de village sauf que il y
avait pas de vigile et sauf que les
lames ne sortaient pas régulièrement et
donc on a des franchissements de seuil
comme ça qui s'observe depuis une
trentaine ou une quarantaine d'années et
c'est ce que moi j'appelle l'érosion du
processus de civilisation en repartant
des travaux du de l'historien du
sociologue Norbert Elias qui qui parlait
de ce process de civilisation il faisait
remonter ce mécanisme ce processus à la
sortie du Moyen-Âge je vais très vite ou
comment dans les cours royales
européennes on avait
progressivement développer un code de
bonne conduite développer une des codes
de politesse de savoir-être donc il a
des pages chavoureuses donc sur comment
la fourchette a fait son apparition dans
les cours européennes sur comment on a
appris à se moucher dans un mouchoir et
plus dans sa manche et cetera et cetera
donc tout ça peut paraître anecdotique
mais tout ça a procédé au long cours à
façonner la psy collective en refoulant
ses affects en apprenant à gérer sa
frustration à se confronter à un cadre
qui peut dire non et à bien évidemment
proscrire le plus possible le recours ou
la montée de la violence ou le recours à
la
violence quand on énumère t les faits
que j'ai évoqué précédemment et on peut
se dire que on est sur on me fait
souvent le reproche une vision assez
sombre assez décliniste sauf que on on
essaie toujours de partir du réel et de
quantifier les choses et donc sur tous
les secteurs de la vie sociale que je
vous ai énuméré pour celles et ceux que
ça intéresse dans mon livre la France
d'après on on montre chiffre à l'appui
la montée de ces de ces
tensions autre petit signe de cette
agressivité être cette moindre capacité
alors je dis pas de toute la société
bien évidemment mais d'une partie de nos
concitoyens à gérer tout cela c'est la
façon dont des expressions comme le
pétage de PL ou le pétage de câbl sont
aujourd'hui monnaie courante on parle de
ça toute la journée et donc si vous
faites l'étymologie rapide hein le
pétage de plomb c'est une surtension sur
un système électrique et donc le plomb
saute pour protéger le reste du système
mais donc il y a il y a surtension et le
pétage de câble c'est un terme qui
provient du langage maritime c'est quand
un bateau était amarré le câble euh avec
le courant le bateau dérivant le câble é
tendu le câble finit par claquer péter
et le bateau part à la dérive et donc
cette expression du pétage de câble nous
dit bien la moindre capacité d'une
partie de la population à gérer ses
affects sa frustration pour toute une
série de raisons comment est-on arrivé
là al on va pas il y a beaucoup
d'étudiants dans la salle donc on va
repasser le le ballon au aux jeunes
générations mais je pense
que tout ça et elas l'explique bien
tout ça se construit notamment dès le
plus jeune âge et donc on parle souvent
de l'école mais l'école à forte àire
c'est d'abord dans les familles que les
choses se passent et donc la le
développement d'une forme
d'éducation comme on a on l'a appelé qui
éducation positive
bienveillante moi je reprendrai un terme
c'est la la sacralisation de l'enfant
roi et bien n'aide pas du tout le jeune
individu à se construire ces réflexes et
incorporés inconsciemment ces réflexes
qui ont participé au processus
historique de
civilisation ça ça se produit dès le
plus jeune âge mais notre jeune individu
va grandir il va devenir adolescent puis
jeune adulte et ensuite adulte et il va
rentrer dans notre société de
consommation
d'hypercommation qui sacralise à son
tour le client roi quand il va aller
chez McDo on va lui dire de venir comme
il est pas besoin de faire d'efforts on
l'acceptera puisqu'il est le client
L'Oréal lui répète matin midi et soir
que il le vaut bien et donc tout ça
participe aussi à cette construction
psychologique qui fait que le jour où on
va être confronté à un N à une autorité
à un refus les choses sont où a une
frustration les choses sont beaucoup
plus dur
à encaisser accepter que par le passé et
et donc les les épisodes de pétage de
plomb ou de pétage de câble se
multiplient et ça tous les étages et y
compris maintenant dans des milieux ou
en direction de public ou de figure qui
étaient encore il y a une vingaine ou
une trentaine d'années relativement
protégé de par leur statut de ce type de
de phénomène et donc si on regarde bien
euh la presse quotidienne régionale les
réseaux sociaux vous voyez espèce de
bruit de fond comme ça qui se développe
euh très très fortement alors bien
entendu et heureusement toute la société
française n'a pas basculé la dedans
processus de civilisation qui s'est
construit sur des siècles euh est quand
même assez résilient mais il suffit que
une partie de la population partage
moins ce type de mécanisme pour que la
société devienne moins vivable et que le
fameux vivre ensemble dont on nous parle
matin midi et soir soit beaucoup plus
compliqué à à appliqué au quotidien que
dans les textes
euh on ce ce processus d'érosion de la
la de la civilité a aussi partilier je
pense ça c'est les linguistes qui nous
le disent à avec la moindre maîtrise du
langage dans les jeunes générations donc
on attend avec impatience les dernières
livraisons du classement
PISA pour voir où situe la France mais
euh vous voyez bien quand on discute
avec des enseignants que en arrivé en 6e
et donc par la pour la suite de leur vie
on a à peu près 10 % d'une classe d'âge
qui est en difficulté et donc c'est
quelque chose de très bien connu
c'est-à-dire que ce qu'on arrive pas à
verbaliser ou exprimer euh avec des mots
on l'exprime d'une autre d'une autre
manière et donc euh tout ça participe
aussi à à ce processus de d'érosion de
la de la civilité qui pose euh des
problèmes qui sont euh absolument euh
redoutable et qui encore une fois je
reviens
qui conduisent un certain nombre
d'institutions des groupes bancaires La
Poste à organiser des sessions de
formation pour comme on dit en bon
français que leur personnel de front
office donc c'est ceux qui sont devant
mais on pourrait dire aussi maintenant
qui sont au front et bien apprennent à
absorber à encaisser cette
décharge d'agressivité d'incivilité
d'une partie de leur euh de leurs
clients ou de leurs usagers euh les
restaurateurs aussi sont confrontés à ce
type de pratique avec ou de comportement
avec des des clients très indélicats qui
vont parler tout fort euh qui vont
organiser la visioconférence dans une
salle de restaurant et et donc la
réponse qui fuse à chaque fois qu'on ose
faire une petite remarque c'est j'ai
payé j'ai droit hein donc on là on
revient sur la société du client euh
donc tout ça nous pose des des
difficultés insurmontables et
euh on on était jusqu'à présent dans le
stade des incivilités mais vous voyez
que si vous faites monter la température
et bien d'agression verbale on peut
passer à l'agression physique
l'agression lourde et cetera et cetera
et donc comme le tabou de la violence
est est est est levé dans une partie des
situations il peut ensuite par contagion
se se se propager dans d'autres dans
d'autres type de situation le deuxème
euh élément
structurant mouvement un peu tectonique
structurant qui à mon de mon point de
vue contribue à ce caractère très très
déstabilisé et très très insécurisé de
notre société française c'est l'emprise
croissante du trafic de drogue dans
notre pays donc je crois que une
commission du Sénat a entendu il y a
quelques jours euh des responsables des
services de sécurité et des de la police
et et de la gendarmerie pour qui ont
livré un
diagnostic tout à fait objectif sur
l'état du du phénomène en source ouverte
comme on dit le ministre de l'Intérieur
avait indiqué il y a de ou 3 ans qu'on
avait 4000 points de D en France et donc
il y a pas une ville moyenne de province
qui n'a pas son quartier sensible avec
son point de Deal ça fait partie
aujourd'hui du paysage commun de la
France d'après euh cette géographie se
superpose quand on y regarde d'un peu
près quand même assez à celle des
violences urbaines et à celle des
émeutes que nous avons connu l'été
dernier c'est-à-dire qu' on crée un
noyau criminogène de 10 de quelques
dizaines voir centaines d'individus dans
les quartiers les plus importants bien
évidemment c'est pas toute la population
de ces quartiers c'est même pas toute la
jeunesse de ces quartiers mais il suffit
que vous ayez typiquement à la monnaie
d'après la mre de la ville
50 80 100 individus sur un quartier de
5000 habitants et le quartier Est le
quartier part à la dérive et c'est une
autre loi que celle de la République qui
progressivement
s'installe avec là ai des
franchissements de seuil c'est-à-dire
que on a un double phénomène à la fois
une diffusion de ce trafic des points
les plus chauds vers les territoires
qu'on croyait historiquement les plus
épargnés on va prendre au hasard une
petite ville de du morbillan Vann Vann
il y a le quartier Carcado où on on a un
trafic de drogue qui est enquisté depuis
des années et donc l'image est déépinale
de Vann c'est pas celle d'une cité du du
narco mais pourtant euh cela existe
deuxième phénomène à côté de celui de la
la diffusion géographique c'est celui du
franchissement de seuil dans la
structuration euh du deal avec des
moyens financiers de plus en plus
importants et le fait que dans les
quartiers où ce trafique s'est implanté
précocement aujourd'hui il y a un ordre
parallèle à celui de la République qui
s'est installé c'est-à-dire que c'est
eux qui contrôlent le quartier
euh le ministre de le ministère de
l'Intérieur s'est félicité que les
émeutes aient été éteintes en quelques
jours par rapport à 2005 ça avait duré
15 jours de moins on a mis 40000
policiers gendarmes pour éteindre
l'incendie quand il y en avait eu 15000
euh au pic des émeutes de 2005 donc il y
a eu une réponse policière et
sécuritaire plus importante mais c'est
aussi que dans tous ces quartiers-là au
bout de TR qu jours certains ont sifflé
la fin de la récrée c'était pas les
maires qui ont sifflé la fin de la
récrée c'était les dealers en disant il
faut que le business
reprenne autre signe manifeste de cette
prise de contrôle
souterrain par ces groupes sur des
cartes des territoires entiers le fait
que aujourd'hui ces monnaai courantes
que les dealers installent des
checkpoints où on contrôle les papiers
d'identité des entrants et des sortants
euh qu'on construisent aussi des
barricades avec des gravats et le signe
le plus évident de tout cela c'est quand
vous vous lisez justement encore une
fois la presse quotidienne régionale et
quand on vous relate le bilan d'une
descente de police par exemple dans les
quartiers nord de Marseille jusqu'à il y
a 5 6 ans c'était le nombre d'armes
saisies le kilo de cheat
et les billets en espèce et le nombre
d'intermélation donc aujourd'hui il y a
toujours tout ça et on vous rajoute le
cubage de grava encombrant et autres que
la voirie embarqué derrière les fourgons
de ce vient ensuite déblayer parce que
il y a une occupation physique du
territoire avec la la volonté de marquer
son territoire alors à la fois un peu
dans une logique moénageuse on
construit des barricades des hers et
cetera et cetera et puis aussi il y a la
conquête des cœurs et des esprits
c'est-à-dire que on achète la population
du quartier les fameuses nourrices mais
bien plus que cela autre anecdote donc
on va quitter le morbillan on va aller
maintenant dans dans le concluse à
Cavaillon la cité du docteur aimé
Cavaillon là aussi voyez petite petite
ville Cavaillon il y a sa cité difficile
avec son point de Deal et cet été après
les émeutes un travailleur
social se déambule ou se déplace dans ce
quartier et constate que on a installé
une grande piscine gonflable avec un
toboggan donc je se dit encore un coup
de la mairie qui a voulu nous squeeer
alors que c'est nous les associatifs qui
faisons le travail donc un peu courussé
ilaelle la mairie et la mairie lui dit
mais c'est pas nous qui avons installé
la
piscine c'était le les dealers qui
avaient installé la piscine pour et bien
qu'il faisait chaud on est à Cavaillon
on est en plein été pour que la jeunesse
du quartier puisse cell qui ne partent
pas en vacances puisse profiter de ce ce
type d'activité et donc quand on se
replace dans de
l'histoire de notre République hormis la
période de la
Résistance dans l'Hexagone en tout cas
quand est-ce que le monopole de la
violence physique légitime et du
contrôle territorial par l'État a été
contesté à la République sur des
territoires du pays jamais c'est la
première fois que cela arrive et tout ça
se métastase et se multiplie un peu
partout en
France et donc voyez qu'on est sur des
choses de nature différentes he le
processus de décivilisation les tensions
accrues entre les relations inter
individuel et
l'incrustation de ce trafic de drogue et
donc
euh jusqu'à présent certains qui n'habit
pas dans ces quartiers se disaient en
fait c'est pas si grave que
ça puisque les règlements de compte ils
se les font entre eux ça fait toujours
ça de moins sur le terrain ensuite sauf
que vous voyez que depuis ces derniers
mois comme ils visent assez mal et qui
sont très bien armés on a aujourd'hui
des victimes collatérales hein donc
samedi dernier il y a un père de famille
de 55 ans qui a trouvé la mort à Dijon
dans son lit euh en plein sommeil
victime d'une balle perdue qui avait été
tirée par des dealers qui voulaient
marquer leur présence et contrôler le
point d'il et donc il dormait au premier
étage mais la K47 si vous maîtrisez pas
ça ça peut arroser un peu haut et donc
les policiers on relevé 60 douilles au
pied de au pied de l'immeuble ça c'est
10jens vous savez il y a une une belle
chanson de Francis Cabrel qui raconte
une histoire d'amour entre rencontre
amoureuse entre deux jeunes et ça
s'appelle un samedi soir sur la terre si
vous regardez la PQR on pourrait se dire
un samedi soir en province c'està-dire
que tous les weekends aujourd'hui vous
avez ce bruit de fond
voilà et donc ça pose des problèmes qui
sont absolument gigantesques à notre à
notre République et à notre état dans
des pays qui se sont pas construits
autour de l'État comme et les services
publics comme on l'a fait en France où
l'État central est moins
puissant je ne sais pas si on peut le
dire au Sénat parce que ça va pas être
diplomatiquement correct c'est en en
présence d'une revue internationale mais
prenez des pays comme la les Pays-Bas ou
la
Belgique l'état centrale est en train de
perdre la main face au deal on protège
la fille de la reine du de du des
Pays-Bas par la présence policière on a
on protège aussi des des élus belges et
dans toutes les villes portuaires où la
coque arrive par tonne aujourd'hui la la
fem use mocro mafia qui est d'origine
marocaine est en train de prendre le
contrôle et donc dans l'histoire de nos
sociétés occidentales alors le cas
italien avec la mafia est particulier
jamais les états centraux ont été
contestés à ce à ce point-là avec une
capacité corruptrice qui commence à se
voir y compris dans et en direction des
élus locaux avec par
exemple une une affaire faire dans la
banlieue de rouan à quanteleu une petite
commune de 10000 habitants où une une
mère a été entendu par la police et la
justice parce que elle avait cédé à la
pression d'une famille délinquante qui
tenait le deal dans son quartier et qui
aujourd'hui et bien de
manière comment dire souterraine mais
très bien connu par la population à
avait aujourd'hui imposé sa loi je vous
raconterai une dernière anecdote parce
que j'ai déjà beaucoup parlé les élus
locaux sont en première ligne on a
d'autres acteurs qui sont également en
première ligne vis-à-vis de ce trafic ce
sont les bailleurs
sociaux qui voit s'implanter le deal
dans leur bâtiment et donc on un
directeur d'office HLM de deal de France
m'a raconté l'anecdote
suivante ils avaient des bâtiment sur
une place d'une ville de de banlieu un
autre groupe immobilier avait d'autres
bâtiments en face où était implanté du
deal et le l'autre groupe a eu la bonne
idée de ravaler les façades et donc le
deal s'est déplacé dans l'immeuble qui
était contrôlé par la société dont la
personne était avait la direction donc
les choses se sont passées comme elles
ont pu se passer à leur tour ils ont
ravalé équipé des nouveaux digicodes et
cetera et cetera et
le jour J on est venu inaugurer donc le
préfet en gant blanc le maire le
président de l'office HLM les
entreprises de BTP donc tout le monde
était là en surface et le patron de
l'office HLM lui va se garer et on lui
demande de faire le tour il va garer sa
voiture en sous-sol et en sous-sol il
voit un type à casquette qui lui dit de
ce garer là et cetera qu'il ne
connaissait pas donc il remonte et quand
il demande à ses services on lui dit que
le type à casquette ne fait pas partie
de l'effectif et donc au moment où la
République coup le cordon en surface en
sous-sol les deal avent repris le
contrôle donc c'est ça aujourd'hui de
mon point de vue un des enjeux majeurs
de la société parce que c'est plus
concentré sur les quartiers nord de
Marseille ou sur le 93 c'est 4000 points
deal et c'est en train de déstabiliser
la République tout entière merci de
votre
[Applaudissements]
attention merci beaucoup Jér Fouret pour
ce
portrait qui qui n'est pas
optimiste mais qui qui regarde de plus
près cette France d'après que vous
décrivez par vos par votre travail on a
voulu justement c'est le Valtin est une
revue qui essaie de de faire le Paris de
de l'échelle pertinente qui essaie de
prendre du récul vis-à-vis des de de
l'histoire de des phénomènes politique
et on a voulu essayer de regarder
l'embrasement français aussi à partir
d'un point d'observation particulier
vous l'avez mentionné g Fourquet dans
votre dans votre intervention un
proposant à Giovanni hursina qui est
donc professeur à la Louis de Rome euh
de nous donner à voir de l'extérieur
mais aussi de l'intérieur parce que nous
faisons partie d'une construction
commune euh cet embrasement euh Giovanni
Orina a par ailleurs signé un article
remarquable que je me permet de vous
conseiller dans le dernier volume de de
la revue donc je me permets de vous le
montrer et je lui cède tout de suite la
parole encore
merci merci merci Gill merci euh au
Sénat au grand continent et pour cette
invitation
euh je vais essayer de développer ici un
raisonnement général car je ne prends
certainement pas le risque d'enseigner
la France au français et je lis parce
que mon
français n'est pas très fort et c'est
c'est mieux pour essayer de clarifier ma
pensée et si j'ai du temps je citerai
plutôt l'expérience italien comme
exemple pour compléter ce que les autres
intervenants diront plus SP on dit et
diront plus spécifiquement sur les cas
français
relier la montée des mouvements
populistes la la proteste politique
relier cette proteste au processus de
mondialisation néolibérale n'est pas une
opération particulièrement originale
euh l'explication là est plutôt linéire
à partir de la fin des années 90 est
avec une accélération à partir des
années excusezement à partir de la fin
des années 70 et avec une accélération à
partir des années 90 une structure
politique et sociale solidement centrée
sur la prédominance et l'autonomie des
marchés mondiaux s'est établi dans le
monde
occidental avec la Grande Récession de
la fin de la première décennie du 21e
siècle cette cette structure est entrée
en crise générant une réaction politique
qui a pris diverses formes qui remonte
grossièrement à la catégorie du
populisme ça c'est
l'exlication de la de la proteste
politique comme une conséquence du
néolibéralisme et de la crise du
néolibéralisme je pense qu'il est très
difficile d'ignorer ces schémas dans
lesquels il y a évidemment beaucoup de
vérités et je pense qu'il est impossible
de nier que les troubles politiques des
15 dernières années sont en quelque
sorte lié au processus d'intégration
mondiale mais l'interprétation que je
propose ici cherche cependant à examiner
plus en profondeur les liens entre
néolibéralisme et populisme en partant
de la conviction que les deux mots
néolibéralisme et populisme n'est donc
qu' unee description partielle des
phénomènes qu'ils prétendent
décrire je pense qu'il vaudrait mieux
éviter de qualifier de néolibéral la
phase historique comprise entre la fin
du 20e et le début du 21e siècle pour
des raisons parce que les mot
néolibéralisme a été utilisé avant tout
dans son C polémique ce qui a affabli
son pouvoir analytique et parce que Cees
concept attribu une centralité excessive
à la dimension économique ce qui a
certainement une grande importance mais
pas
exclusive ensuite le début de la fin de
20e siècle ne doit pas être placé dans
les années 70 comme le font ceux qui
utilisent le concept de néolibéralisme
mais une décennies plutôt à la fin à la
fin des années 60 dont les décennies
suivants ne peuvent ne peuvent être
détachés selon l'interprétation que je
propose entre la fin des années 60 et le
début de 21e siècle s'est formé un ordre
que je propose d'appeler régime
historique libéral
radical ça c'est une conception plus
large du néolibéralisme mais à la
possibilité de com pe dire avoir le
néolibéralisme dans les cons comme une
partie d'une d'une d'une idée plus plus
large qu cette régime historique libéral
radical je pense que ce régime présent
les caractérisques suivants ce régime a
une solide matrice individualiste
universaliste antirtraditionnaliste et
utopique qui est précisément l'héritage
du climat spirituel des années 60 la
raison car je pense qu'il faut partie
des années 60 pas des des années
70 cette régime a une Pée tout aussi
vigoureuse vers la
dépolitisation qui peut également être
considéré dans une large mesure comme
une conséquence de la matrice
individualiste et universaliste dont
j'ai déjà
dit 3è caractère l'accent mis sur les
formes non politiques de gouvernance et
d'organisation de la vie humaine
associée trois formes non politiques
notamment les droits la morale et les
marchés ces TR ces trois formes se
déclinent évidemment dans le sens de
l'individualisme et de l'universalisme
chacun des la fin du 20e siècle c'est
caractérise par la prédominance des
utopies antipolitique ou du moins
d'utopie
apolitique les droits les marchés et la
morale ça veut dire que l'interprétation
que je propose reconnaît un rôle central
au marché mais ce rôle n'est pas
original ni exclusif l'histoire ne
commence pas à la fin des années 70 avec
les tournants néolibéral mais avec le
changement des climats historique des
années 60 le néolibéralisme avec son
accent sur les marchés est une manière
de répondre à ces changements mais
seulement une manière parmi d'autres
moyens d'autres
manières
finalement ces processus cet régime
historique libéral
radical place de plus en plus la vie des
individus sur la domination des systèmes
abstrait une partie de la littérature
des années 90 qui exprime le régime
historique libéral Radic
dans sa forme les plus mature mettre
l'accent s la prédominance de l'abstrait
sur les concret je pense par exemple à
Anthony gidens et la nécessité pour les
humains de devenir de plus en plus
capable de contrôler
l'abstraction que
que que j'entend par demande des système
abstrait la prévalence des systèmes de
règles impersonnelles les règles du
droit du marché de la moralité sur les
pouvoirs concrets des individus les
pouvoirs
politiques les caractères
décontextualisé de ces systèmes de
règles qui ont en valeur universelle et
sont légitimés par leur universalité et
la possibilité d'être défendu sur des
bases
rationnelles par conséquent les dénis ou
la minimisation du rôle du contexte
historique politique et
communataaire et finalement la
prévalence du futur sur les présents les
Sy systèm abstraits sont légitimés dans
dans les présents par leur capacité à
Prom à promettre pas nécessairement
maintenir les contrôles du futur ce sont
les caractères je pense de ce
régime historique libéral radical qui
débute qui a son début à la fin des
années 60 et je pense son appoget dans
les années 90 et entre dans sa crise au
début du 21e siècle
euh bien sûr la Grande Récession à la
fin de la première décennie de 21e
siècle démontre que les systèmes
abstraits sont en réalité incapables de
garantir le contrôle de l'avenir et cela
alimente les racines socio-économiques
de la protestation politique qui va
exploser au cours de la 2e décennie du
21e siècle toutefois comme le montre une
abondante littérature scientifique la
protestation n'a pas seulement des
racines
socioéconomique mais aussi des racines
culturel psychologique éthique
géographique et
cognitif en m'appuyant sur sur le
raisonnement que je viens de développer
sur le régime historique libéral radical
ma proposition interprétative et que la
protestation politique est aussi
peut-être avant tout une protestation
contre
l'abstraction et j'ai eu l'occasion de
l'écrire dans les grands continents en
citant les grands romans les roman
impossible presquisible de stepano d'
Rigo orcinousorca c'est une protestation
de
vistokoki qui en français a été traduit
comme touché de doigt contre les les oui
dire en
protestation du concret de la percession
concret
contre
l'abstraction l'abstraction cont
laquelle on proteste est abstraction
éthique l'imposition d'une éthique
universaliste sur les moralités locales
mais peut-être plus encore il s'agit de
l'abstraction cognitive la domination
des systèmes abstraits généraliste et
universaliste dans notre façon de
connaître le monde et la distance
croissant entre cette forme de
connaissance et l'expérience quotidienne
d'individus
concrets l'abstraction du régime
historique libéral radical contrib à la
Libération intégrale de l'individu à
travers sa
décontextualisation mais comme l'ont
récemment démontré les neuroscien rares
sont les individus qui savent réellement
vivre dans ce monde
décontextualisé c'est-à-dire
reconstruire réflexivement leur propre
contexte individuel sorte de contexes
individuel portable dé contextualisé et
ces gens sont minoritaires en Occident
et quasiment non exist en dehors de
l'Occident les neurosciences Redon
l'image d'un être hum qui a certes
besoin de liberté individuelle mais
aussi dansun contexte moral et
social obser sous cet angle la catégorie
du populisme la rébellion de bon gens
contre les mauvais élite risque d'être
aussi insuffisant que celle du
néolibéralisme est en fait la
littérature internationale sur le
populisme est chaotique divergent
contradictoire et P
concluant il serait préférable je pense
d'observer la protestation politique
comme une réaction au régime contre le
régime historique libéral radical en
travaillant sur des catégories telles
que l'abstrait et les concrets les
proches et les longemps les contexes et
la
décontextualisation les présents et les
futur Clement en conclusion sur les cas
italiens quel est là l'exemple de
l'Italie l'Italie est une démocratie
excentrique un pays qui appartient à
l'Occident sans sans au doute mais qui
est aussi à la périphérie de l'Occident
au sud de l'Italie nous sommes en
Afrique du Nord à l'Est de l'Italie dans
les Balcans des parties du monde qui
certainement n'appartien pas à
l'Occident l'Italie a toujours beaucoup
de mal à revenir à l'universalisme
occidental dans les différentses
versions angloax français mass aussi
soviétique ont été adopté par ces élites
par les élites italiens mais pas pour
les
pays l'Italie a toujours été aussi un
pays très
contextuel un pays décentralisé
extraordinairement
hétérogène avec d'innombrables points de
vue riches de traditions locales
profondément en
raciné en Italie selon les données de
2019 Pr près de 70 % de la population
vivent dans des communes de taille moyen
entre 5000
et50000 habitants seulement 15 % de la
population italienne vit dans les grand
villes il n'y a pas une mégalopole
Comparis Rome a 3 million
d'habitants l'Italie aussi connu une
crise politique particulièrement profond
qui attend son apogé un 92 93 lorsque
les partis gouvernementaux ont été
balaillés ça veut dire que la politique
n'a pas suffisamment réalisé son travail
de médiation entre les contextes
italiens la contextualisation italienne
on peut dire et le processus de
décontextualisation mondiale ce qui a
laissé un espace particulière à la
montée de la protestation politique
c'était une protestation contre
l'incapacité d'une politique trop faible
à adapté les pays à à les à les défis de
la mondialisation au défi de la
mondialisation on comprend alors qu'en
Italie la protestation politique est été
particulièrement précoce robuste et
désordonné et dans une large mesure il s
condensé à nos mouvement comme les
mouvements C étoiles dans lesquels la
rébellion du concret du contextuel du
contrôlable contre l'abstrait était
particulièrement visible les M 5 étoiles
c'était un mouvement de la rébellion de
du contrôlable du contexte contre l'idée
de
l'abstraction dans le même temps et
paradoxalement la faiblesse de politique
a permis à la contestation la
protestation politique de s'exprimer
sous une forme politique et
institutionnelle de entrer dans les
institutions de se politiser modérant
son pouvoir destructeur et finalement
facilitant sa ré réabsorption d' moins
jusqu'à maintenant
merci merci beaucoup merci beaucoup
giovann Orina pour cette cette éclairage
italien cette mise en perspective
historique et aussi cette grille de
lecture que vous avez déployé avec avec
beaucoup de virtuosité et qui est très
utile je pense pour nous aider à
comprendre proche lointain contexte
décontextualisé abstrait concret et et
dans cette grille de lecture justement
Françoise fressose vous avez suivi vous
suivez vous chroniquez cette vie
française depuis depuis plusieurs années
et la question que que envie de vous
poser pour cette dernière intervention
liminaire peut-être de 10 minutes qui Ta
ensuite ouvrir les échanges avec la
salle pour pour poursuivre la discussion
elle est assez large au fond comment
documenter cet embrasement français
alors il y avait merci de me donner la
parole il y avait deux possibilités pour
documenter cet embrasement français soit
je prenais des statistiques des chiffres
soit je vous raconter un peu ce que j'ai
pu observer parce que j'ai la chance
d'avoir un certain âge et d'avoir pu
suivre la vie politique française disons
depuis les années 1982
1983 j'ai eu aussi la chance de voir pas
d'un d'une d'un seul prisme c'est-à-dire
j'ai pu suivre la gauche la droite tous
les camps et donc et j'ai pu suivre
plusieurs présent de la République et
donc j'ai pu au fond me faire un peu
l'idée de ce qui était arrivé à notre
pays alors ça peut être très partial
hein ça peut être c'est mon
interprétation qui peut être discuté
mais voilà ça me paraissait intéressant
de de partager avec vous euh pour
documenter le l'embrasement français oui
il y a crpool bien sûr sur lequel je ne
reviendrai pas qui est un fait divers
qui marque énormément parce que il y a
cette violence dans dans dans un village
et puis il y a la tentation d'une partie
de la population de dire on va se faire
euh on on va faire vengeance parce que
l'État ne nous protège plus donc ça
c'est voilà les aimutes urbaines dont
vous avez parlé très forte cet cet été
qui montre qu'au fond une partie des
citoyens français ne se sentent plus
citoyens puisque ils attaquent des
symboles de la République les mairies
les écoles y compris dans les quartiers
où ces symboles jouent un rôle très
important et tout ça parce que ils ont
l'impression que la société est injuste
qu'il y a pas d'intégration et que la
République une et indivisible qui fond
de notre engagement n'existe plus
j'ajouterai deux deux
éléments complémentaires moi ce qui m'a
beaucoup frappé dans les dernières
années c'est la répétition des révoltes
fiscales c'est-à-dire alors on a bien
sûr les gilets jaunes sous le premier
quinquena d'Emmanuel Macron qui nous a
tous frappé parce que il y a une
irruption de violence incroyable à ce
moment-là mais il y avait eu aussi les
bonniss
rouges pendant le quinquenna de François
Hollande et à chaque fois qu'est-ce qui
se passe l'état croit bien faire il
croit il il doit financer la transition
écologique la taxe carbone moi ce qui
m'a frappé c'est qu' elle était
pratiquement unanimement admise par les
partis politiques qui nous gouvernent
comme quelque chose de d'essentiel pour
arriver à financer et et accomplir la
transition écologique et tout d'un coup
une partie de la population réagit avec
une violence inouie parce que c'est
vital pour eux c'est-à-dire vous nous
taxez avec cette taxebonne vous la fait
monter en puissance sur 5 ans et on va
tomber en dessous de du SE où on peut
vivre on va être en en survie et on va
mal vivre et ça moi pour moi ça a été
aussi révélateur au fond d'une cécité
c'est-à-dire il y a une partie de la
population qu'on qu'on ne capte plus
quand on est homme politique qu'on ne
voit plus parce que soit il vote plus
soit il ne se manifeste plus euh et soit
aussi la société a énormément évolué et
voyez ce qui ce qui m'a beaucoup frappé
dans la révolte des des gilets jaunes
c'était ces familles ces femmes qui élev
seul leurs enfants qui on sont souvent
abandonnés par leurs compagnons qui ne
touchent
pas la pension qui leurit d et qui sont
absolument voilà donc ça c'est c'est
c'est des choses qui m'ont énormément
frappé ces derniers temps ce qui m'a
frappé aussi c'est le fantôme qui a pesé
sur le double quinquena de d'Emmanuel
Macron c'est-à-dire essayer de faire
revivre le Conseil National de la
Résistance qu'est-ce que c'est que ce
conseil nationale de résistance 1944 on
est en guerre on est en en occupation et
on a des partis qui sont alors forts
mais très antagonistes qui parviennent à
se mettre autour d'une table et qui
réussissent à inventer le modèle social
français sur lequel on vit encore
aujourd'hui impossible d'arriver à ne
serait-ce qu' un consensus sur l'état du
pays et les réformes dont on a besoin le
corps vous vous souvenez pendant la
réforme des retraite le patron du corps
qui dit non non il y a pas de déficit et
puis quand Emmanuel Macron aura fait la
réforme ah bah si il y avait un déficit
et il va maintenir et ça ça m'a
énormément frappé parce que je pense
qu'on est à un moment clé où on est à la
fois un pays qui a 56 % de dépenses
publiques dans la richesse nationale 40
% de prélèvement obligatoire et qui en
même temps va devoir financer un nombre
de charges essentiel pour l'avenir à la
fois parce que la population vieillli
parce qu'on est en quête euh évidemment
de de de d'un bien veillir et qu'en même
temps comme la population vieillit au
fond on peut pas demander aux même de
financer le le le système social sur
lequel on vit par ailleurs on a cette
échéance de la transition
écologique qui va demander des milliards
d'euros d'investissement qu'on ne sait
pas financer et le fait pour moi que des
partis politiques qui sont quand même
euh qui qui sont pas populistes en fait
qui sont capables de raisonn ne
parviennent pas à ce diagnostic commun
et à cette nécessité d'essayer de
rebattre les cartes moi m'interpelle
énormément et ça me fait penser ça ça a
été surtout le sentiment que j'avais
sous le quinquen de François Hollande
qu'on était à la veille de la Révolution
c'est-à-dire que vous savez quand sous
Louis X on cherche à essayer de rebâtir
territorialement le pays et de rebâtir
au fond un nouveau système fiscal et
qu'on y'y arrive pas parce que les
acteurs sont trop faibles il y av un peu
ça et aujourd'hui ce que je ressens un
peu moi en regardant les élus c'est de
se dire il y a tellement de choses qui
nous ont échappé aujourd'hui que on y
arrive plus donc à la limite il va
peut-être mieux mettre la poussière sous
le tapis et puis on espère que ça
continuera comme ça sans trop craquer
mais ça craque de plus en plus alors
qu'est-ce qui est arrivé pour que ces
partis alors je parle des partis
politiques mais je pourrais parler aussi
des partenaires sociaux là aussi où on a
on aurait envie qu'au fond
la CFDT d'M mer revienne quoi qui qui
qui qui qui se qui reprennent du du nerf
qui disent voilà on participe à la
modernisation du pays je pense qu'ils
sont trop faibles aujourd'hui
pour porter une part de l'intérêt
général dans une construction politique
où les Français ont tendance à plus trop
voter à plus faire confiance et que
maintenant on est plutôt dans bah on va
essayer de défendre ce qu'on peut encore
défendre dans un système qui coule voilà
c'est un peu l'idée que j'ai comment en
en estant arrivé là euh en
m'interrogeant je me suis dit évidemment
c'est très lié à l'affaiblissement des
deux parties qui se sont partagé le le
pouvoir depuis les années 1980
c'est-à-dire le LR d'aujourd'hui qui a
été ensuite avant le grand parti
gouliste et puis le Parti socialiste
dont on voit aussi aujourd'hui l'État
alors qu'est-ce qui est arrivé dans ces
deux parties euh une fuite des militants
euh une perte de leadership et je pense
une difficulté à appréhender ce qui
s'est passé et là je rejoins tout à fait
le diagnosticque qui a été fait
précédemment c'est-à-dire la
mondialisation libérale qui a été un
choc absolument colossal sur toute le le
monde occidental les États-Unis l'Europe
et qui nous a touché et peut-être qui
nous a touché plus que les autres et là
je rejoins beaucoup l'analyse de Marcel
gaucher en fait Marcel gaucher qui dit
de tous les pays de tous les états on
était peut-être les moins armés à euh
rencontrer cette grande vague parce que
on s'est construit sur l'idée d'un État
fort d'un état toutpuissant et on nétait
pas du tout armé pour affronter cette
mondialisation qui au fond a détruit
progressivement toute cette force
étatique euh le moment clé pour moi
c'est
1983 euh 1983 c'est François mitteran
qui euh euh s'est fait élire de 2 ans
plus tôt en disant au français je vais
vous changer la vie grand espoir et il
va faire la relance dans un seul pays
pendant 2 ans en espérant que en
convoquant les États-Unis à Versailles
il allait pouvoir convaincre le
président américain de faire la relance
dans la foulée la relance ne marche pas
et on se retrouve avec des dévaluations
répétition des grandes difficultés je me
souviens qu'à l'époque ça ça m'avait
beaucoup marqué c'est l'Arabie Saoudite
qui nous a prêté à un moment donné parce
qu'on avait plus d'argent dans les CAES
de l'État et ça ça m'a énormément frappé
en disant mais voilà on est obligé
d'aller voir du côté des pays du golf
pour voilà et dans l'imaginaire de la
gauche
1983 c'est la trahison c'est c'est
associé à la rigueur et deuxièmement
c'est associé à la parenthèse
c'est-à-dire la gauche va vivre sur
cette illusion que ce n'était qu'une
parenthèse et qu'on reviendra à un
moment très fort et très puissant et et
c'est d'ailleurs jpin qui l'a qui l'a
alimenté et donc il a eu si vous voulez
pour la gauche française une très grande
difficulté par rapport à ce qui se
passait à la même époque avec Tony Blair
avec Gerard schuder c'était l'idée que
il fallait rester quand même très
socialiste et ne pas
voir ne pas adapter la doctrine à ce
monde nouveau qui apparaissait du côté
de la droite je pense que ch est devenu
un européen mais petit petit c'était pas
sa conviction profonde au départ et on
voit bien que ce qui a frappé aussi le
la vie du pays c'était les deux
référendum sur l'Europe le premier
Maastricht ou miteron pensait avoir 55 %
et ça se finit à 51 % et le second 2005
où le nom triomphe à 55 %. et quand je
me quand je m'interroge sur la façon de
de qu'est-ce qui s'est passé pour qu'il
y ait une telle antagonisme sur cette
mondialisation et ben c'est je trouve
que le bouquin de Jérôme Fourquet la
France sous nos yeux est est formidable
parce que on voit en fait il explique
tout ce qui s'est passé c'est-à-dire
qu'on voit tous les bouleversements qui
se sont produits en 40 ans qui ont été
d'une violence incroyable c'està-dire
qu'on voit la la désindustrialisation du
pays on voit le rôle de la grande
distribution qui à la fois détruit les
petits commerce dans les villages mais
qui assuré aussi la nourriture à à la
population parce que en ayant ses prix
bas et et ils ont quand même garanti ils
ont été je pense que si le mouvement des
gilets jaunes aurait été beaucoup plus
puissant s'il y avait pas eu le rôle
amortisseur de la grande distribution
qui avait des prix bas pour faire vivre
toute cette population qui était euh qui
qui qui n'a pas les salaires qui sont au
niveau requis et et qu'est-ce qu'on voit
aussi on voit les centr-villes la la la
la polarité entre les entre les
métropoles et puis les onur urbaine et
et donc on voit cette dstructuration et
puis la cette France des loisirs qui a
été en fait qui nous permet de vivre et
qui explique aussi tout ce qui s'est
passé autour du travail le travail qui
était une force très intégratrice et au
fond qui est devenu beaucoup moins
centrale parce que il y a aussi la
partie loisive et quand vous mettez en
relation ce que fait apparaître euh le
livre de de de jérôe Fourquier avec
toutes les courbes euh avec toutes les
géographies et le le discours politique
a été tenu pendant toute cette mutation
il y a un décalage énorme c'est-à-dire
qu'à aucun moment les les les les les
transformations de ce pays n'ont été non
seulement assumé mais euh conceptualisé
pour adapter au fond la réponse à ce qui
se passait c'est-à-dire que on n pas
vraiment fait sauf aujourd'hui où on
constate les dégâts pour limiter la
métropolisation ou faire en sorte que
les métropole euh puisse s'occuper aussi
de leur arrière-pays et ça c'est Jupé
qui croit très bien faire à Bordeaux qui
fait un travail remarquable dans sa
ville et qui constate au moment des
gilets jaunes qu'au fond il est contesté
par une partie de la région parce que il
a trop embelli sa ville par rapport au
reste du territoire donc vous voyez il y
a tout tout toutes ces situation et
alors pour pas être trop longue ce qui
me frappe aussi c'est que le le le parti
qu'elle vend en poupe aujourd'hui c'est
le rassemblement national et en fait
qu'est-ce qu'elle a fait Marine Le Pen
elle a transformé un parti d'extrême
droite en essayant de revenir à une
fibre gauliss républicaine et elle
essaie de nous faire fantasmer sur le
retour au trente glorieuse c'est-à-dire
une France qui était la France gaulise
des TR glorieuses où chacun était maître
de son destin et était heureux dans son
pays or on voit aujourd'hui que tous les
pays tous les problèmes et notamment ce
que soulève Jérôme Fourquet c'est-à-dire
le problème de la drogue ce sont des
problèmes qui sont extrêmement liés à
aux réseaux internationaux et donc la
question à mon avis qui se pose pour
tous les politiques aujourd'hui c'est
d'essayer de repenser tout ce qui nous
arrive de le voir de voir la réalité en
face alors que il y a eu trop de
tentative de mettre sous le tapis les
les problèmes pour essayer de d'inventer
des outils de régulation qui soient
adapté à la situation à laquelle à
laquelle on vit je dis pas que c'est
facile parce que je pense qu'il y a une
conjonction de sujets effectivement
éducation effectivement les banlieux ça
je pense que c'est un problème parce que
on a tant tant que on on
mettait une certaine partie de la
population dans un tel territoire et que
ça n'affectait pas le reste on sen
contentait ce qui se passe aujourd'hui
c'est qu'on voit que les banlieux bah ça
commence à infuser sur de la de la
société de la population et que ça pose
des grands problèmes et donc il y a un
travail
euh de refonde de toute la pensée et des
méthodes de de de de de politique alors
là encore l'autre sujet qui me semble
important c'est que on a des institution
qui piège c'est-à-dire que on est en fin
de cycle on se dit oh là là on est foutu
ça y est le pays va pas s'en sortir puis
tout d'un coup arrive dans la campagne
électorale
un quelqu'un qui va dire bah si ça ça y
est j'ai la solution et puis on
s'accroche à ça et en fait on se
découvre que non il y a pas il y a pas
de solution et le sujet là que je me
pose en ce moment c'est plutôt que
d'avoir des très grandes ambitions pour
le pays est-ce qu'il faut pas repartir
de la base essayer de refaire du
maillage de citoyenneté au plus près du
terrain travailler la citoyenneté en
réengageant les les les citoyens dans
peut-être dans des actions modestes mais
qui interfèrent avec son voisin pour
recréer des des des zones au fond de de
de dialogue et de faire ensemble voyez
ce qui ce qui m'a frappé dans les
dernières choses qui qui sont arrivés
c'est les conventions citoyennes créées
par Macron j'ai eu la chance de pouvoir
assister à aux deux aux deux deux
dernières et ce qui m'a beaucoup frappé
c'est que autant le résultat de
final est sujet à caution parce qu'on
n'arrive pas à voir comment ça va être
traduit dans les faits il faut pas que
ça interfère sur le travail des élus
mais en revanche quand les personnes
sont travaillent
ensemble et font œuvre commune
c'est-à-dire arrivrive à à discuter
entre elles et à produire quelque chose
d'intéressant pour le bien général il on
en tire une richesse absolument
incroyable et donc moi qui été au début
très tenté en disant voilà la la France
est un grand pays il faut porter au nos
ambitions je suis plutôt dans la période
actuelle à me dire revoyons nos
ambitions à la baisse mais essayons de
faire que la citoyenneté au moins sur le
terrain reprennent un peu de vigueur
parce que sinon on va vers des drames
assez épouvantables
merci merci beaucoup Françoise fressos
nous avons un VI encore une demi-heure
avant de mot de conclusion du président
Larcher et on voudrait ouvrir le le
dialogue entre les intervenants de ce
soir et la salle en commençant bien sûr
par par le président de la commission
des lois du S du Sénat qui nous fait
l'honneur de de de
d'intervenir ce que je vous proposerai
c'est d'entendre les trois interventions
on endra par la suite la VI président de
la commission des affaires étrangères du
Sénat Catherine Duma et le présent la
commission de la culture de l'éducation
et la communication du Sénat Laurent
Laffond je vous propose de peut-être de
faire les trois interventions avant de
par la suite faire un tour de table et
de prendre quelques questions du public
en
clôture merci je vous promets d'être
assez rapide euh beaucoup de choses ont
été dites euh beaucoup de choses
importantes ont été d le président de la
commission des lois que que je sais
aujourd'hui va plutôt vous donner le
regard de de notre commission et de ce
que nous voyons nous de là où nous
sommes il est incontestable que nous
vivons une crise de l'autorité alors
même que cette autorité est légitime
elle s'appuie sur notre système
électoral et sur des élections
démocratiques certes sur une
participation de moins en moins
importante à ces élections mais légitime
et pourtant cette légitime cette
légitimité même est interrogée voire
même
contestée et dans ces conditionsl
évidemment ça crée des
situations de contestation un peu
j'allais dire fondamental qui font que
la parole aujourd'hui des élus est de
moins en moins reconnu en tous les cas
de moins en moins écouté de telle façon
finalement au bout du compte contesté
c'est vrai pour les grands élus
nationaux c'est vrai pour les élus
locaux naturellement j'ai été maire
pendant 20 ans d'une commune du
département du Rône j'ai vécu des
moments difficiles un jour un monsieur
se présente à l'accueil de la mairie
avec un grand couteau comme ça en disant
je viens pour tuer le maire bon ça s'est
arrêté assez vite mais j'ai aussi fait
des réunion dans des quartiers ou un
quartier un peu difficile à l'époque je
suis ressorti ma voiture avec quatre
peneus crevésis un samedi matin sur un
de mes marchés il y a un de mes
concitoyens qui étaaiit pas très content
d'une décision que j'avais prise qui me
menaçait fortement si cette situation
devait se reproduire aujourd'hui je
pense que l'homme qui est venu avec une
arme se serait débrouillé pour arriver
jusqu'à mon bureau sans se poser trop
question je sais pas où je serai encore
aujourd'hui que ma voiture aurait brûlé
plutôt qu'avoir les quatre pene crevés
et que le concitoyen sympathique sur le
marché m'aurait proablement donner un
coup de boule assez fort parce qu'il
était vraiment très énervé tout cela a
changé et a changé radicalement et cette
crise de l'autorité bah finalement elle
gère de plus en plus de contestations
violentes et que cette contestation
violente évidemment s'attaque au symbole
de cette autorité la crise des gilets
jaunes vous l'avez rappelé tout à
l'heure et la parfaite illustration
entre 2018 et 2018 et 2019 les symboles
de l'autorité ont fait l'objet d'une
contestation majeure qu'il s'agisse
d'ailleurs des bâtiments symboliques les
préfecture notamment ont été prises pour
cible parce que c'est l'état territorial
qui était contesté et cette période vous
avez rappel vous avez bien fait de
rappeler tout à l'heure l'affaire des
bonniss rouges parce que c'est à peu
près de même nature et qu'il s'agisse
aussi des représentants de l'État à
commencé par les forces de l'ordre et
plus récemment les élus locaux mais
l'épisode de la Zade de Notre-Dame des
Landes au début des années 2010 marquait
déjà une position de défiance à l'égard
de l'autorité et de ses décisions y
compris lorsqu'elle était conforté
d'ailleurs par des décisions de justice
plusieurs recours jugés je crois qu'il a
plus d'une vingtaine ou d'une trentaine
plusieurs ont été jugés donnant raison à
la puissance publique au projet et
pourtant la contestation a été là depuis
d'ailleurs la remise en cause de
l'autorité récurrente on l'a vu sur les
retraites on l'a vu avec la grande
bassine de sainte Soline et encore plus
récemment avec les émeutes du mois de
janvier et du mois de juillet le
principe même de l'usage de cette
violence légitime par l'État est lui
aussi remis en cause seul en France dans
ce pays démocratique les forces de
police ont la possibilité de de de
pouvoir utiliser la force la violence
c'est ce qu'on appelle la violence
légitime et aujourd'hui cette violence
là est interrogée puisqueà chaque fois
que les services de police interviennent
dans les opérations de maintien de
l'ordre ce que l'on conteste c'est les
violences policières sans se poser la
question une seule seconde que si elles
ont eu lieu c'est parce que avant il y a
eu des comportements qui étaient des
comportements naturellement
inacceptables et qu'il fallait bien que
au nom de la sécurité publ les choses
reviennent dans l'ordre un exemple je
ferai très vite je suis allé avec la
commission des lois il y a un peu moins
de 2 ans à Bièvre qui est le lieu de
d'entraînement du raid et de nos CRS et
j'ai interrogé un un je ose dire un
vieux CRS un CRS expérimenter qui m'a
dit monsieur le sénateur il y a quelques
Ann années 30 ans en arrière à peu près
un peu moins de 30 ans lorsque l'on
arrivait sur une manifestation sortait
de nos camions avec nos équipements ça
se calmait assez vite et puis les choses
se passaient à peu près normalement
aujourd'hui quand nous partons nous
savons qu'on va être caillassé que ce
sera la guerre et qu'on pourra peut-être
mourir voilà la réalité de ce que vivent
aujourd'hui nos forces de l'ordre alors
on peut imaginer qu'il s'agit d'une
perte de repère démocratique que
évidemment la contestation du pouvoir ne
se fait plus dans les urnes par les
élections comme C habituellement mais
par une contestation de principe à la
fois de l'organisation de l'État et à la
fois de la société mais c'est une
contestation qui est quand même malgré
tout en tous les cas il faut encore
l'espérer minoritaire dans la société
mais ultra agissante ultraagissante et
ultra organisée et qui naturellement
profite des nouveaux modes de
communication que sont les réseaux
sociaux tous les dispositif qui existent
de nos jours y compris d'ailleurs euh
des chaînes d'information continues je
veux pas jouer les vieux réactionnaires
je veux pas dire qu'il faut pas utiliser
ces outils là et ce que je veux dire
c'est que ce sont des moyens qui
décuplent complètement ces actions
violentes et qui font qu'à un moment un
autre on ne parle plus que de ça voire
même on donne des idées à certains ce
sera le cas d'ailleurs on le verra dans
le travail que nous menons aujourd'hui
sur les émeutes qui se sont passé au
printemps dernier alors tout cela est
bien inquiétant et quel est le rôle de
de la commission des lois dans cette
situationl nous avons deux commissions
d'enquête qui sont en cours une qui est
commune avec le président Lafond qui est
le président de la commission des de
l'éducation des affaires culturelles et
sportives que nous menons ensuite de
l'affaire de du crime de Monsieur Samuel
pati et donc là nous essayons de voir
comment l'État il en parlera sûrement
l'éducation nationale s'est organisée et
comment malgré tout on on arrive encore
au CRIM et au drame de Monsieur Bernard
il y a quelques mois encore quelques
semaines et puis une autre commission
qui porte effectivement cette fois-ci
commission d'enquête sur les émeutes du
mois de juin dernier on a interroge
beaucoup pour essayer de comprendre le
phénomène pas seulement se contenter de
ce que l'on peut entendre ici et là mais
comme le documenter comme disent
aujourd'hui les les chercheurs faire un
travail de fond et bien imaginez nous
constatons d'ors et déjà la confirmation
de ce que vous venez de dire ce que vous
avez dit notamment le rôle des
narcotrafiquants il y a d'ailleurs une
commission d'enquête qui est mise en
place au Sénat en ce moment qui va
démarrer C qui a démarrer ses travaux
mais il y a ça mais il n'y a pas que ça
il y a aussi la remise en cause
fondamental de notre organisation
démocratique de notre système
institutionnel combattu sur le plan
politique dans des endroits de la nation
notamment à l'Assemblée nationale
singulièrement par un groupe particulier
mais combattu aussi par des moyens
agressifs et violent dans la rue et
c'est tout cet enjeu qui est là il
interroge cet enjeu là et j'en
terminerai par là notre destin collectif
on se demande aujourd'hui ce qui fait
encore nation on se demande encore
aujourd'hui où sont les discours
politiques qui font nation qui permett
mettront à chacun et chacune d'entre
nous de retrouver ce que l'on recherche
peut-être de façon un peu chimérique sur
ces 30ente glorieuses de retrouver le
destin collectif partagé l'ambition
collective partagé mais aussi la propre
réussite individuelle de chacun et
chacune d'entre nous et donc ce destin
collectif aujourd'hui il est plus
qu'interrogé il est parfois même même
combattu remis en cause il faut donc
qu'on le réinvente il faut vraiment le
réinventer pour le sauver parce que
sinon nous aurons des lendemains
difficiles alors je ne suis pas pas
pessimiste j'ai plutôt envie de
convoquer Alain qui disait que le
pessimisme était de caractère et
l'optimisme était de volonté il faut je
crois que cette fois-ci sur le plan
politique une fois que le constat
objectif sera fait documenté il est
multifactoriel il y a des
responsabilités dans tous les milieu et
de partout c'est incontestable et nous
devons faire vite si nous voulons demain
pouvoir continuer à vivre dans ce beau
pays qui est le nôtre parce qu'il reste
un beau pays
merci merci beaucoup monsieur le
Président Madame la vice-présidente euh
de la commission des affaires étrangères
du Sénat Madame Catherine
Duma bien mesdames messieurs bonsoir euh
tout comme François Noël buffet je vais
essayer de porter le regard non pas de
sa commission mais de la nôtre de la
commission des affaires étrangères de la
défense et des forces armées du Sénat et
peut-être essayer de dire que comment ce
qui se passe dans le monde a un effet
sur cet embrasement dont nous parlons
l'embrasement de la société dont nous
parlons je voudrais tout d'abord excuser
bien sûr mon Pr président Cédric Perin
qui conduit une délégation actuellement
à New York pour rencontrer ses
homologues à l'Assemblée général des
Nations unies notamment le secrétaire
général de l'ONU Antonio guterz et je ne
doute pas d'ailleurs que cette
délégation parlera aussi de de ce monde
fracturé et on l'a vu ce monde fracturé
on le partage il n'est pas qu'à
l'échelle de la France il est à
l'échelle du monde alors ce monde
fracturé comment peut-il en être
autrement je dirais pour parler de de
revenir à notre pays 2 ans après
l'attaque et de l'Europe 2 ans après
l'attaque de la Russie sur l'Ukraine
dont le nombre inimaginable de victimes
nous a renvoyé à la brutalité d'une
guerre de tranchée en Europe que nous
croyons elle aussi appartenir au passé
on pensait qu'il n'y aurait plus de
guerre comment serait-il autrement aussi
après cette attaque terroriste d'Israël
don par le Hamas dont l'aurore dépasse
l'entendement il y a un engrenage de la
violence au Proche Orient il s'est
réenclenché avec lui le risque bien sûr
d'embrasement de toute une région et
pour la France le risque de
l'importation du conflit
israélo-palestinien alors parler d'un
embrasement français ne relève pas d'un
simple débat théorique mais
malheureusement d'un risque actuel et
avéré et c'est le premier point que je
voulais souligner du point de vue de
notre commission nos grands témoins ont
la légitimité scientifique
pour parler de ce monde fracturé et ils
l'ont fait différemment d'ailleurs et
c'est ce que je trouve peêre très
intéressant dans ce débat il y a une
partie plus philosophique avec le
professeur monsieur fourkel l'a traité
autrement et d'une façon plus concrète
en nous parlant de la France
d'aujourd'hui et puis madame fressos
nous a parlé de de la
politique des des 40 dernières années
euh je peux en tant qu'élu de Paris en
tant que parlementaire de Paris aussi
témoigner comment ce monde fracturé
touche tout le territoire euh dans la
capitale nos concitoyens vivent des
bouleversements de leur quotidien ce
dont on a parlé d'ailleurs très
longuement je peux témoigner de
l'irruption d'une violence qui ne
connaît ni limites ni frontières je peux
moi aussi témoigner euh des dealers dans
leur territoires réservés euh où la
République n'est presque plus présente
je peux témoigner de l'apparition de
nouveaux clivages dans nos sociétés euh
qu'il s'agisse de communautarisme de
séparatisme et puis aussi madame fressos
je peux aussi témoigner euh de la
fracture des territoires ruraux euh qui
sont très qui est très importantes cette
fracture et au Sénat euh qui est
l'assemblée des territoires on le
constate vraiment à la commission des
affaires étrangères nous avons aussi en
partage un sujet avec la commission des
lois qui est le sujet de sécurité
nationale et de la lutte contre le
terrorisme le terrorisme dont on sait
qu'il peut résulté d'influence étrangère
sous forme de prosélitisme et aussi de
manipulation de l'information euh c'est
un sujet qui nous préoccupe et qui
participe bien sûr à l'embrasement de
notre pays l'utilisation par des
puissances étrangères de médias
audiovisuels très performant qui
s'apparent à des organes de propagande
étatique qui sont parfois aussi forts
que certains états nous posent problème
comme d'ailleurs à la commission de la
culture où je sais qu'on on travaille
sur ces sujets les puissances hostil
peuvent utiliser la liberté d'expression
de nos démocrati parlementaires pour
véhiculer de fausses informations
manipuler l'audience des réseaux sociaux
la prise de conscience que la France et
plus largement les pays européens sont
des cibles de choix des ingérances
Russes chinois turqu mais bien d'autres
est un vrai sujet et nous avons dans
notre commission travaillé beaucoup sur
ces sujets et nous avons notamment un
certain nombre de de travaux
parlementaires qui parlent de ces sujets
sur tous ces sujets notre commission
reste mobilisée pour analyser les causes
les conséquences de ce monde qui est en
plein vertige un monde plus que jamais
divisé euh comme l'a dit le président du
Sénat les préoccupations des Français
guident nos travaux quotidiens au dans
cette commission euh nous nous nous
félicitons de la tenue de ce colloque
qui va alimenter nos futures euh
réflexion et celle de la France de
demain et puis je voudrais finir par une
note peut-être plus personnelle euh par
rapport à ce qui a été développé j'ai
trouvé très très intéressant par le
professeur Orsina je voudrais peut-être
lui poser une question et poser la
question celle de l'abstraction est-ce
que c'est l'abstraction qui qui conduit
à l'abandon des valeurs euh je pense que
c'est une question importante pour notre
société euh parce que on voit bien que
quand on parle de l'autorité mais on
parle avant tout de valeur et cette
absence de valeur cette absence de
respect on voit bien que qu'elle un
certain nombre de problèmes et puis
peut-être un dernier mot par rapport à
ce qu'a dit Madame
fressos en effet on peut se poser nous
les politiques est-ce qu'il faut avoir
de très grandes ambitions vous avez
raison pourtant je suis une Gauliste et
j'ai l'AMB beaucoup d'ambitions pour mon
pays mais c'est vrai que au-delà des
grandes ambitions ne faut-il pas
retravailler sur le sujet des valeurs
merci
beaucoup merci beaucoup madame
viceprésidente Catherine on entend
Laurent Lafond président de la
commission de la culture de l'éducation
et la communication du Sénat merci et en
3 minutes je vais essayer de vous parler
de l'école avec l'espoir de ne pas trop
vous démoraliser après une série de
propos qui pe peut-être vous paraître un
peu pessimiste je je vais aborder la
question de l'école à travers la la la
perte de confiance des Français dans
dans le système scolaire il y a un peu
moins de 2 ans ici même au Sénat dans le
cadre des agoras que nous organisons sur
le thème de l'éducation nous avions fait
un un sondage avec le CSA qui avait
montré que un Français sur deux était
sceptique sur le fonctionnement de
l'école ce qu' avait de plus inquiétant
dans ce sondage c'est que ceux qui font
vivre l'école au quotidien ceux qui le
font fonctionner qui consacrent leur
carrière professionnelle je parle
évidemment des enseignants éta encore
plus sceptique que les Français
eux-mêmes sur l'école puisque ce sondage
montrait que les 3/4 des enseignants
estimaient que l'école fonctionne mal
actuellement et que près de 80 % des
enseignants sont pessimistes quant à
l'avenir d'école alors comment en est-on
arrivé là pour douter ainsi du du du
système scolaire quel sont les raisons
qui font que notre euh confiance dans
l'efficacité du système scolaire est
remise en cause on pourrait en parler
longuement je vais essayer de prendre
trois éléments qui participent de cette
méfiance par rapport à à l'école d'abord
il y en a un qui est connu qui est
largement dans le débat public c'est la
question de la la baisse du niveau euh
du niveau des des des enfants quand ils
sortent du système scolaire en
particulier en français en mathématique
sur les deux savoirs fondamentaux
savoirs fondamentaux pourquoi d'ailleurs
pourquoi les appelle-t-on fondamentaux
parce que ils permettent l'accès à la
connaissance et à la compréhension et
aussi parce qu'il participe à
l'insertion sociale des des des jeunes
adultes quand ils sortent du système
scolaire encore récemment le le ministre
de l'éducation nationale disait que un
élève sur deux en 4e maîtriser mal la
lecture c'est une illustration du du
niveau de de de scolarité enfin du
niveau atteint dans les dans les savoirs
fondamentaux deux remarques sur cette
question des des savoirs fondamentaux
d'abord qui nous a appris que les
savoirs fondamentaux la connaissance
diminuait ce ce n'est pas notre système
éducatif c'est les enquêtes
internationales et notamment celle de
faite par PISA qui a montré deux choses
d'abord que nous n'étions pas dans les
premiers rangs mais plutôt dans entre
les 25 la 25 et la 8e place selon les
les les discipline et que d'une certaine
manière ça traduisait un un déclassement
du système scolaire français par rapport
à à d'autres pays et que surtout on
pouvait mieux faire puisque d'autres le
faisaient avaient des résultats beaucoup
plus satisfaisants et puis l'autre chose
que nous a montré ces enquêtes c'est que
ce qui est censé mesurer
le niveau des des élèves à la fin de
leur cycle scolaire le bac ben alors que
le niveau scolaire baisse le taux de
réussite au bac augmente ce qui montre
une chose me semble-t-il c'est que
malheureusement le bac ne veut plus dire
grand chose je dis malheureusement parce
que dans
notre imaginaire c'est plus que dans
notre imaginaire not vécu collectif le
bac c'est déjà une reconnaissance
sociale c'est non seulement l'accès au
système de l'enseignement supérieur urs
mais c'est une forme de de réussite de
reconnaissance de récompense d'un
travail et qui aujourd'hui en tout cas
ne se matérialise pas par rapport à
l'obtention du bac deuxième élément de
de la perte de confiance
c'est la perte de confiance sur
l'efficacité du système scolaire comme
un élément d'asscenseur social dans
l'histoire de la de la
République l'école l'école publique elle
est étroitement liée à cette idée que
quand on rentre à l'école à 3 ans et
quand on en sort à 16 ans on peut passer
d'un milieu social à un autre à travers
l'acquisition du savoir heureusement ce
système fonctionne encore mais il a des
grandes failles il a des grandes failles
territoriales vous en avez parlé et
c'est toute la problématique deéducation
prioritaire où on voit bien que malgré
les efforts et notamment budgéaires qui
ont été mis en place on arrive
difficilement à creuser l'écart entre
les enfants selon les territoires dans
lesquels ils sont éduqués Ilim
évidemment sur la question social je
voudrais juste sortir un chiffre parce
qu'il est peu connu finalement 2 % des
jeunes de 15 ans seraiit inactifs selon
l'in c'estd inactif en dehors du système
scolaire en dehors d'un système de
formation alors même qu'à 15 ans on est
censé être encore à l'école 2 % ça
pourrait paraître faible mais 2 % ramené
au nombre à une classe d'âge c'est quand
même 15000 jeunes qui sont d'une
certaine manière en errance en dehors du
système scolaire ce qui est évidemment
inquiétant et puis troème élément de la
perte de confiance c'est la question de
la violence alors évidemment l'école
n'est pas en dehors de la société tout
ce que vous avez pu dire sur une
expression différente de la violence et
une expression plus inquiétante de la
violence il y a pas de raison que ce que
nous ressentions en dehors de la société
on ne ressemble pas également au sein de
l'école je voudrais juste faire de
remarques sur cette question de de la
violence et peut-être en l'apprenant pas
uniquement à travers la violence
physique mais la contestation deux
remarques qui qui nous sont apparus avec
François Noël buffet dans la commission
d'enquête auquelle il faisait allusion
sur les les suites de la l'assassinat de
Samuel Patti évidemment elle est très
difficile à quantifier cette cette
violence mais les acteurs que nous avons
auditionné nous disent qu'elles prennent
une nouvelle forme à travers deux euh
deux zones qui étaient jusqu'à présent
un peu épargnées d'abord l'école
primaire qui jusqu'à présent était peu
soumise à des phénomènes de contestation
ou ou voire de violence et qui désormais
l' également alors certes dans des
ampleurs qui restent mesuré mais c'est
et la deuxième chose qui m'a
personnellement beaucoup frappé c'est
que ceux qui sont à l'origine de cette
violence ou de cette contestation c'est
pas tant les élèves mais les parents
voilà et dans votre interview que j'ai
lu avec beaucoup d'attention monsieur
fouet la semaine dernière vous parliez
du du tissu et du c'est l'éducation
n'est pas que le résultat de l'école
mais est un résultat une chaîne plus
large qui bien sûr intègre les parents
et et le phénomène que la contestation
de l'école Vienne par des parents
eux-mêmes est évidemment un élément de
d'affaiblissement de l'école dernière
remarque sur sur la question de la
contestation c'est bien
sûr je crois que c'est le président
larch qui qui qui en parlait le
phénomène d'autocensure la moitié des
enseignants disent s'être autocensuré
dans dans une partie de leur leur
enseignement évidemment c'est un
phénomène assez inquiétant euh
puisque cette autocensure porte beaucoup
sur sur les questions de religion
d'éducation sexuelle notamment de de
connaissance de
l'histoire alors qu'est-ce qui fait que
des enseignants puissent peuvent
démissionner en fait renoncer comme ça
je crois qu'il faut surtout pas les
culpabilisé de ça mais ça me
l'interprétation que j'en ai
personnellement ça me renvoie beaucoup à
la notion d'enfant roi que vous avez
identifié tout à l'heure où finalement
même les les le
l'école qui est le creusé même de la
citoyenneté qui forme le le citoyen qui
prend l'enfant tel qu'il est tel qu'il
vient de son de son milieu de son
territoire et qui ont fait un citoyen en
lui apprenant une une libre pensée
l'école faibli sur cette aspect là et
puis vous avez dit pour caractériser
l'enfant roi le slogan de de de McDo je
crois venez comme vous
êtes avec cette per cette forme de
renoncement qu'on peut assister cette
autocensure c'est non seulement venez
comme vous êtes mais vous en sortirez
comme vous êtes entré et ça c'est
évidemment un phénomène un peu
inquiétant désolé de finir sur cette
note pessimiste moi je reste convaincu
que l'école est notre bien commun et que
notre capacité à réagir ensemble sur ce
sujet fondamental de l'école nous
permettra de redresser l'école et de
retrouver le bon
chemin merci
beaucoup merci beaucoup monsieur le
Président alors petit changement de
programme on va pas faire le tour de
table tout de suite on va d'abord ouvrir
à la salle pour peut-être deux questions
brève histoire que ensuite on groupe ses
questions et que vous puissiez répondre
donc si vous voulez vous manifester oui
mademoiselle ici si vous pouvez faire
passer un micro il y a un micro qui
arrive une
minute si vous pouvez vous présenter
très brièvement au au début de la
question bonsoir à tous donc je
m'appelle Sarah brunou je suis
consultante en en renseignement
d'affaires pour les entreprises qui
s'implantent au
Moyen-Orient donc effectivement je
regarde aussi beaucoup ce qui se passe
dans la géopolitique du MoyenOrient mais
là ma question serait plus sur le
constat de la violence que vous avez
fait
et et donc la question ça serait
effectivement donc cette défiance envers
l'autorité est-ce qu'elle serait pas
elle pourrait être aussi corrélé à en
fait comment dire une une réponse de
l'État par la force croissante est-ce
que donc face je parle notamment donc
des mouvements sociaux gilets jaunes et
cetera est-ce que justement cette
répression croissante souscouvert
effectivement de ne pas vouloir traiter
tous les problèmes et de mettre un peu
les problèmes sous le tapis est-ce que
finalement comme vous parlez
effectivement qu'en 2005 on avait 5000
personnels des forces de l'ordre qui
Inter interviennent contre 40000
aujourd'hui est-ce queil y aurait pas
donc dans cette volonté de pas voir les
problèmes de répondre plutôt par la
force
euh voilà ma
question et notamment je voudrais juste
ajouter tout ce qui concerne les
phénomènes de désobéissance civile qui
sont en fait des actions non violentes
en fait est-ce que cette défiance
vis-à-vis de l'État vis-à-vis de l'école
aussi aurait donc une conséquence dans
ces actions non violentes qu'on voit
souvent dans les mouvements
contestataires écolog
une deuxième brève question au fond s'il
vous plaît et puis ensuite je pense
qu'on redonnera la parole à nos
invités
réement est un qui est nécessaire
làdessus la question qui
arrive
comment pourquoi comment on est r là
pourquoi il n'y a pas l'audace
nécessaire un service civque obligatoire
le ré ement de dans les quartiers où il
des pourquoi on est à ce pointl empêché
de faire ce qu'il fa merci beaucoup euh
donc effectivement on avait pas assez de
d'objets de
discussion ajouté un peu le la MACR
crise dans laquelle nous sommes je vous
demanderais une gentillesse c'est
possible de maintenir vos je sais que
c'est difficile il y a beaucoup de de de
de points à discuter maximum 5 minutes
chacun pour qu'on puisse quand même
avoir par la suite le plaisir d'écouter
les conclusions du président l'archer
donc peut-être on commence on commencera
par le on commencera par le par par
Jérôme
Fourquet euh oui alors peut-être me
concernant plutôt sur la la première
question euh effectivement on on entend
parfois que le maintien de l'ordre à la
française euh pourrait être générateur
de de tension dans les les mouvements
sociaux il faut néanmoins se rappeler
que pendant longtemps ce maintien de
l'ordre à la française a été pris en
exemple dans beaucoup de de démocratie
occidentale donc savoir comment est-on
arrivé là
euh le sénateur buffet parlait de son
échange avec des un CRS
expérimenté qui lui avait sans doute
aussi parlé du fait qu'à l'époque quand
il avait commencer sa carrière même si
il y avait parfois des manifestations
volantes parce qu'on fait l'histoire en
disant que tout ça était un le flleu
tranquille mais les manifes de metétalo
dans les années 70 c'était quand même
quelque chose ils étaient aussi
confrontés à un mouvement social
organisé en cas adré par des services
d'ordre et vous avez vu que lors de la
mobilisation sur les retraites quand les
syndicats même si comme Françoise
fressos l'indiqué les syndicats sont
aujourd'hui plus affaiblis qu'il ne
l'était dans un premier temps les
manifestations sont déroulées
relativement de de manière relativement
pacifiée donc il y a cette scénographie
si je peux dire de du de la mobilisation
sociale avec la la la la le
surgissement d'acteurs qui aujourd'hui
sont dans dans d'autres formes de
réaction on a vu se développer ce qu'on
appelle les fameux group les blocs de
tête où des des des manifestants qui se
mettent spécifiquement en avant du du
service d'ordre pour aller pour aller au
contact et donc même si
effectivement il y a des choses sans
doute à revoir je pense que ce phénomène
de
violence ne peut pas être en première
instance imputé au au stratégies de
maintien de l'ordre même si comme on a
eu un changement de préfet de police à
Paris euh comme par hasard les
manifestations sont passées de manière
un peu plus paisible donc il y a sans
doute aussi euh dans le nassage ou autre
euh des des choses à les regarder une
fois qu'on a dit ça euh on en a pas
parlé tout à l'heure mais on parlait de
l'autorité du respect de la de la règle
et autres regardez le phénomène des
refus d'obtempérés qui ont littéralement
explosé en France alors qui a donné bien
évidemment euh lieu euh à à la au décès
du du jeune naë mais il y en a eu
d'autres mais il faut regarder les
statistiques policières et des
gendarmerie c'est plusieurs dizaines de
milliers par an et donc là c'est pas
forcément la question du maintien de
l'ordre qui est en question c'est aussi
la question du
consentement d'une partie de la
population au respect de de l'autorité
donc voilà ce que je je pouvais merci
essayer d'apporter comme éclairage merci
beaucoup Giovanni orcina peut-être
oui euh
sur la la relation entre l'abstraction
et la per de valeur et il y a l'idée qui
est très claire dans dans les années 90
que ce système abstrait est aussi un
système de moralisation de moralité il y
a l'idée que la la moralité va être
moralité universelle qui est la la
reconnaissance de l'être
humaine tant queêtre humaine qui est la
la tolérance qui est la solidarité il y
a une idée que la la société
posttraditionnaliste va perdre les
valeur traditionnel traditionnau mais
bâti de nouveaux des nouveaux valeurs
morales universel le problème c'est que
ça c'était l'idée la théorie et il y
avait aussi beaucoup de de politistes
américains qui disaient que il y avait
des données qui démontrait que les
jeunes générations étaient plus
universalistes et que la l'insuffisance
sans universalisation c'était une
facteur de des des des persistance des
gens plus plus plus plus plus grand et
que avec la le changement
générationnel cette idée d' moralité
universelle peuvait être établie mais je
pense que les les tout la discussion que
que nous avons eu ce soir démontre que
la théorie
n'a pas n'a pas produit une pratique et
que cette idée d'une moralité
universelle est un peu comment on peut
dire
euh n'est pas encore
arrivé merci beaucoup Françoise fr
peut-être je va répondre sur le service
civil obligatoire parce que moi j'étais
très pour je me suis dit mais oui
qu'est-ce qu'il attend Macron pour
décider ça c'est quelque chose qui est
et en fait quand vous regardez le ce qui
se passe c'est que quand ils ont essayé
de le faire euh le premier parti qui a
dit banco c'était le rassemblement
national et tout le camps qui a dit non
c'est la gauche
et le risque c'était qu'au fond une
mesure venue d'en haut et venue de
Macron soit rejetée comme diviseuse et
ça aussi pour moi c'est un symptôme de
la profonde division actuelle du pays
sur l'idée qui devrait quand même nous
rassembler de dire qu'est-ce qu'on peut
faire pour être un peu plus citoyen et
ça c'est c'est c'est une alerte sur
l'état de déch du pays et sur la montée
de la polarisation très
forte on peut éventuellement prendre une
ou deux questions très très
brèves il arrive il arrive il
arrive donc bonjour je m'appelle Marie
Astrid je suis étudiante en histoire SCI
politique à l'Institut catholique de de
Paris et moi du coup j'ai une une petite
question qui vatre très breve c'est en
fait dans un monde polarisé dans un
monde même je dire manière
intelligemment artificialisé
pouvons-nous considérer encore le mot
souveraineté comme étant relatif à la
France notamment dans ce cadre
d'embrasement alors
euh sal alors bonjour je m'appelle Robin
je suis étudiant en 3e année de droit et
de sciences politiques à l'Institut
catholique de Paris alors moi j'ai une
question qui s'adresse principalement à
Jérôme
Fourquet vous avez parlé de divers faits
divers sans jamais évoquer les
conséquences juridiques et judiciaires
qui ont pu avoir lieu par la suite
est-ce que l'embrasement dont vous avez
parlé et la crise de l'autorité ne
serait pas indirectement une conséquence
des décisions trop laxistes des juges et
faut-il créer un système d'évaluation
des juges comme cela existe pour les
professeurs ou bien faut-il réformer la
formation des
juges merci alors question difficile et
tours de table très bref aussi donc le
le défi est assez grand
question al
alors je suis au Sénat et donc au nom de
la séparation des pouvoirs donc je peux
pas me me prononcer sur l'évaluation des
juges ou le contrôle des juges en
revanche quand je en tant que
analyste alifop depuis 20 ans maintenant
de manière constante toutes les enquêtes
qui sont réalisé sur la justice
l'évaluation par les Français de la
justice même s'ils sont pas spécialistes
ils ont pas tous fait des études de
droit la perception que les Français ont
c'est que la justice est insuffisamment
sévère mais dans des proportions énormes
euh même si encore une fois ils ils ont
pas siégé en cours d'assise ils ont pas
forcément eu des proches qui avaient été
exposé à ce type de de décision ou qui
avaient été victime elle-même mais donc
c'est c'est un élément très
ant et je pense que c'est un des
éléments de tout ce qu'on explique
depuis tout à l'heure et il y a eu un
déplacement c'està-dire que dans les
années 90 2000 face à la montée de
l'insécurité l'accent été mis par
l'opinion publique sur la police et la
gendarmerie en disant ils interpellent
pas assez ils sont pas assez présents et
depuis une quinzaine d'années se disent
mais ils font ce qu'ils peuvent mais
c'est derrière c'est l'autre maillon le
maillon de la la chaîne pénale qui ne
suit pas et donc c'est effectivement une
source
d'insatisfaction qui est qui est majeur
et qui contribue aussi à générer cette
société de cette société de
défiance si vous voulez compléter
peut-être
non Françoise fressuse sur la justice
moi je pense que de plus en plus il y a
des consignes qui sont données notamment
on l'a vu au moment des émeutes urbaines
où les consignes données par le Garde
des saau ont été quand même assez
respecté non je pense que le la la
grande souffrance
c'est l'engorgement des tribunaux le
fait que ça ne va pas assez vite et et
et mais je le recrut bon ça le
recrutement je ne me prononce pas mais
en tout cas sur le fonctionnement au
quotidien ce qui est sûr c'est que la
lenteur de la justice est un est un est
un sujet mais je pense que c'est quand
même en train de changer peut-être le
président buffet qui est à la fois
avocat président de la commission des
lois et fait beaucoup de
défaut moi j' envie de répondre à plein
de questions mais je vais pas le faire
pour pas faire dur le temps sur la
justice en particulier pas plus tard que
ce matin la commission des lois rendait
son avis sur les différentes missions
budgétaires et singulièrement sur celle
de la de dans le domaine pénitentiaire
problème de la justice il a il est enfin
il est à la fois il est simple notre
système de justice il tient il y a trois
paramètres la police qui fait son
travail la justice qui juge et la
pénitentiaire qui emprisonne
éventuellement qui poursuit si un de ces
trois systèmes un de ces maillon est
faible c'est fichu donc il faut qu'il
soit complet la police est remonté en
moyen on va dire je rentre pas dans les
discussions sur le les opérations de
maintien de l'ordre c'est pas pas tout
de suite la justice on a redonné des
moyens budgetaires le Sénat a voté
budgets pour pour avoir plus de
magistrats plus de greffiers plus de
numérisation je fais très court et
remettre la justice à niveau ça va
prendre du temps ça va prendre 3 ans
minimum à peu près pour arriver à peu
près à niveau mais la question c'est le
niveau des peines a été encore a été
renforcé c'està-dire que les tribunaux
ont condamné de plus en plus fort la
question de fond c'est l'effectivité de
la l'exécution de la peine et
singulièrement la rapidité de
l'exécution de la peine et c'est là où
nous sommes très mauvais parce que les
peines qui sont prononcées sont
globalement exéc uté mais souvent très
tardivement évidemment ça donne ce
sentiment insupportable mais c'est pas
qu'un sentiment d'impunité et donc
l'enjeu c'est l'effectivité de la peine
et la rapidité de son exécution donc
tout le débat va se poser maintenant sur
le fait de savoir certes placement
détenenstion certes différents systèmes
possibles d'ailleurs je le dis devant le
président du Sénat on a on proposera au
début de l'année 2024 à la commission
des lois une mission assez lourde sur
l'exécution des peines pour essayer
d'aborder le sujet vraiment de façon
fondamentale mais le problème de fond il
est d'abord ici alors après la formation
bien sûr mais l'École nationale de la
magistrature est en train de se réformer
profondément elle est en train de bouger
mais vraiment fortement sur plein de
sujets en nombre de recrutements bien
évidemment mais pas seulement y compris
dans son corpus idéologique dont elle a
besoin mais la directrice actuelle fait
un gros travail dans ce sens-là là aussi
ça prendra un peu de temps voilà j'ai
d'autres j'aurais fait d'autres réponses
mais j'ai pas beaucoup de temps donc
voilà effectivement malheureusement ce
débat aurait pu continuer encore encore
très longuement mais il continue en
ligne il continue dans les publications
qu'on va qu'on va sans doute essayer de
de de mettre en œuvre avec avec le Sénat
euh j'ai le plaisir de effectivement
permettre de vous donner la parole pour
un mot de conclusion monsieur le
Président l'archer ce n'est pas facile
mais je suis sûr que vous serez
l'auteur d'abord je vois que N n'avons
pas répondu à un certain nombre de
questions de main levé euh
en tous les cas peut-être qu'ils
pourront rentrer en contact avec grand
continent parce que ça peut enrichir
tous nos travaux et et toutes nos
synthèse c'est une proposition que je
fais d'abord je voudrais remercier tous
les intervenants de ce soir de dire aux
trois présidents de commission qui sont
là ma gratitude vous voyez qu'ici on
n'est pas uniquement des machines à
examiner des projets de loi des
proposition de loi on essaie de
réfléchir sur les questions de la
société
euh le président la fond faisait état de
la laagora que nous avons conduit les
réflexions sur l'école l'école relève
très peu du législatif et pourtant c'est
un enjeu majeur sur lequel nous devons
apporter notre réflexion et notre
contribution et puis la commission des
affaires étrangères c'est vrai la
réalité de la
mondialisation est-ce qu'il faut
contextualiser on y reviendra et comment
dans la mondialisation retrouver quelque
part des racines qui ont disparu c'est
ce que j'ai compris cher professeur et
puis le président de la commission des
lois vient de nous dire y compris ce qui
fait débat sur la justice euh tout le
monde n'a pas le même regard que le
président sur la justice mais vous savez
pendant 20 ans aucun président
d'assemblée ne s'était rendu à l'École
nationale de la magistrature à Bordeaux
c'était quand même un paradoxe et la
séparation du pouvoir faisait qu'on
vivait dos à dos
alors que nous aurions dû vivre dans une
séparation totale mais aussi dans des
dialogues et dans des ponts l'ancien
ministre du Travail que je suis pe vous
dire que j'ai été le premier ministre du
Travail à remettre les pieds 20 ans
après à l'Institut du travail comme s'il
devait pas y avoir dialogue entre
l'inspection du travail et le ministère
du Travail je pense que on peut être
indépendant autonome mais aussi
dialoguer je voudrais vous remercier nos
intervenants je crois que c'est c était
assez passionnant euh j'ai découvert le
professeur Jérôme Fourquet fait partie
de nos lectures quasi cotidienne
maintenant et Françoise fros nous
conduit à la réflexion et elle a un
regard elle a dit qu'elle avait traversé
du temps mais elle est toujours jeune et
elle peut avoir cette référence qui nous
permet de traverser le temps je vrais
dire à partir de deux mots on m'avait
préparé une superbe conclusion et je
vais pas l'utiliser je vais
repartiressayer de
trouver face à un
embrasement qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire
pour circonscrire
l'incendie puis ensuite reconstruire
c'est comme un feu de forêt comment on
le circonscrit comment on replante et
comment on évite un nouvel
incendi chers professeur vous avez parlé
de l'Italie démocratie
excentrique et au fond quand on regarde
la France c'est une
his
CLI
fondé au début de la 3è République par
lois la loi
1881 et la loi 1884 une pour
l'école et une qui donne la liberté
communale la loi de 1905 on a très peu
prononcé ce mot ce soir qui fonde autour
après un débat passionnel
le principe de
laïcité et puis une autre loi celle de
1901 qui fonde le lien social
qu l'autorisation de s'organiser
librement en
association et écoutant Françoise
pressuse je me disais qu'il faut qu'on
revienne à quelques fondamentaux je
demander professeur à l'oreille tout à
l'heure qu'est-ce que isé il m'a dit
proximité et en fait François pressos
nous a dit c'est sans doute là qu'il
faut retrouver et le lien et la réponse
et le sens dans son intervention tout à
l'heure voilà pourquoi je ça nous
renvoie à la loi communale et à la loi
départementale qui à partir de 1790
donne un sens un périmètre et permet à
des citoyens
d'éclore et je pense que la
mondialisation notre goût du
XXL je fais le cou en général mais ce
qui va bien pour mes chemises ne va pas
très bien pour la société et bien je
vous le dis très clairement je pense que
nous devons retrouver cette proximité et
vraiment c'est ce autour de quoi je me
bat aujourd'hui parce que nous vivons
une société verticale et plus la société
verticale moins au fond l'autorité
s'exerce elle est comprise et je pense
que c'est quelque chose de très
important N n'avons pas évoqué aussi la
disparition peut-être c'était une autre
époque du moule qui a représenté
longtemps le service national et donc
l'idée d'un service national
universel c'est quand même une réflexion
qu'on ne peut pas balayer éternellement
j'ai appartenu je suis toujours jeune
mais j'ai quand même quelques années
d'expérience j'ai appartenu à la
commission
segin qui vous le savez s'était opposé à
A disparition du service national en
posant la question du
moule du moule pour faire métal ensemble
et au fond c'est une question me
semble-t-il qui est posée l'exemple du
refus d'obtempéré et là je fer aussi la
réponse par rapport à la justice comment
voulez-vous que les citoyens comprennent
cher François Noël buffet qu'un
policier
traîné par une moto
le jeune et 15 jours de travail
d'intérêt général c'est incompréhensible
pour les citoyens qui ne croi plus en
l'autorité et donc je pense que
entre effet
mondial européen il faut aussi qu'on
qu'on sorte d'une forme d'individualisme
quand même parce
que la perte de contextualisation c'est
aussi l'individualisme par rapport à me
semble-t-il des valeurs universelles
qu'il nous faut retrouver voilà ce que
je voulais vous dire merci d'être venu
nombreux j'espère que vous avez passé un
moment intéressant en tous les cas nous
ça nous fait un bien fou les
parlementaires alors je voulais vous
remercier et n'hésitez pas à nous écrire
y compris à m'écrire y compris à me dire
que vous êtes pas d'accord parce que
pardonnez-moi le Parlement c'est pas un
lieu fermé certes nous sommes élus nous
par un corps particulier
500000 élus locaux qui sont notre
soubassement mais aujourd'hui dans le
pays c'est les seuls qui ont encore la
confiance majoritaire des citoyens et
donc ça nous donne une responsabilité
particulière nous ne sommes pas que les
représentants des territoires nous
sommes au travers des territoires les
représentant des citoyens qui l'habitent
et ça reste même s'il y a des fiolances
vis-à-vis des élus même si les choses se
dégradent ça reste quand même pour
reprendre une formule qu'on m'a repris
mais que j'aurais dû labelliser
l'élu il reste àortter d'engueelade mais
il reste àortter et parfois d'autres
élus ne sont plus apportés des citoyens
c'est aussi une réalité je vous souhaite
un très bon retour il est 20h05 nous
avons dépassé un peu de TVA le temps qui
nous était imparti mais merci d'être
venu nombreux au
[Applaudissements]
Sénat